Four,
oh,
five,
three,
two,
uno.
Ya Live.
Ladies and gentleman,
Eddie Bravo,
Joey,
motherfucker,
Diaz and Brandon Shah.
I
love you guys too.
Happy New Year.
Motherfuckers.
Everybody who came to the show last
night.
Thanks for coming out.
Sorry we couldn't stick around.
I have.
I've had a stomach bug since Thursday.
I was severely worried that I was going
to shit myself during the show.
I was worried I was going to shit myself
during the UFC and the UFC.
I didn't eat all day and then right
before I'm like,
God damn it,
I got to eat something.
Yeah,
my stomach's been fucked.
My kids had some sort of a bug,
so some sort of a flu.
The whole house had it.
My wife had it,
my daughters had it and I didn't get it
until I got to Vegas and on Vegas I've
worked out with delegate a Thursday and
I was burping and farting.
I was like,
what is going on?
And then the middle of the night I woke
up,
I was like,
oh,
this ain't good,
this is not good.
And then the next day I couldn't eat
anything.
I couldn't.
Hold anything down and right before the
UFC I said,
oh,
I gotta eat something.
So I had some case at Diaz.
I just took a chance and I was like,
I might very well have to sprint to the
shitter.
So I got through that.
Yeah,
it was in the UFC.
I was really worried I was gonna have to
shoot myself,
but I pulled it out and then a wrecked a
bathroom afterwards.
Was that time where you can smell it
coming out of your body and you're like,
what in the fuck is in there?
And then the same thing yesterday I
couldn't eat all day before the show.
Couldn't eat a goddamn thing and then
right before we were in the dressing
room I go,
I got to eat something.
I'm tired or I feel kind of weak.
So I had some cheese and some meat.
So that's why I didn't stick around
after the show ladies and gentlemen.
But if you came,
we had a good God damn time.
I figured yet sick because you made like
a beer meet fucking omelet or some shit
to your family that.
No,
everybody got sick from school,
little kids,
man,
they just get sick.
There's a bunch of them together and
they just somehow or another.
You ever think about that?
Like who?
Who's the first person who got VD?
That'd be one dirty motherfucker.
That was number of.
That has to be a sanction because he
knows kid.
There's one person like VD,
right?
Like that had to come from an individual
first,
right?
I mean it's some.
Every coal has to come from somewhere.
Apparently a lot of the calls we get
come from agriculture.
That's why it's all like swine flu and
shit like that.
The white man brought it here to the
Indians will be like,
hey,
how you doing?
And then they're just sick as fuck and
die.
Dude.
We went over that the other day and a
podcast.
Ninety percent of all native Americans
were wiped out by diseases that they
didn't have an immune system for.
When the Europeans came to the 1500.
So I can wipe any more weight.
Didn't actually killed in battle.
No,
no,
no more of them died by disease.
Believe it or not.
Fucking 90 percent of the population.
It's really crazy where she get that
from the library.
We're not doing that today.
Eddie Bravo.
What figure
library.com.
Yo.
So a UFC 207.
That was one of the.
One of the craziest events of all time
and watching that main event was it was
like there was.
It was surreal.
First of all,
it's surreal because I was.
My body was all weirded out because I
was a little out of it.
What about the shit all over my chair,
but it was also,
it was just bizarre.
That was the least competitive like main
event other than although in Mcgregor,
but that was one dynamic shot to the
chin that knocked him out.
Like everything about that was off.
Can you knit?
Can you think about another main event,
championship level where it was that
kind of big of a discrepancy?
You know what I'm saying?
Like it wasn't even a fight and I think
leading up to it,
there was some kind of red flags that
you saw leading up to it.
If you think back now that we should
throw,
everybody said right physically,
physically,
physically.
She looked great,
but like what's,
what kind of sparring was she doing?
You know,
one of the things I was thinking when
she was hitting pads,
she's sitting there hitting pads with
Edmond.
I was like,
they're standing right in front of each
other.
Like she's not moving.
She's just hitting pads,
pop,
pop up of.
Tough to tell though,
right?
Because sometimes they do it for the
camera.
If the countdown crews there,
you don't want to show your new shit.
But also what did people think was gonna
Happen?
Like did you think this whole time when
she's shooting these movies,
doing southern admin her come up with a
plan for her to stick on the outside jab
and move.
That's not,
that's not in her DNA anyway.
She had to close the distance and
clench,
you know,
shouldn't be the only plant.
The idea of standing with Amanda Nunez
is just ridiculous.
The difference in punching power is like
literally doubled,
but we've seen her fight take punches
before who a batch could hit pretty
hard.
I'm not saying similar,
but no,
I'm saying what bench did.
She has decent power and she's a very
aggressive.
She throws volume strikes,
but she throws her arms.
She doesn't hit nearly as hard as Amanda
and Amanda.
Torques or whole body in his shit.
I agree Jo.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's and batches arm for this long and
Dan got damn telephone poles and that's
all fine,
but don't you think the game plan should
have been get her to the ground and she
tried that a little bit.
She didn't.
She was already lit up.
She wasn't there though mentally that
that's why I'm saying there's,
there's things leading up to it and I
think the biggest red red flag for me,
and you know Dana better than anyone,
he's a promoter through and through one
of the,
if not the best of all time.
I can't think of another one.
Don King I guess,
but still for him to say,
yeah,
you can skip all the media shit and just
focus on the fight.
I was like,
God,
that just doesn't seem right.
You know why she's managed by or she's
handled by William Morris Endeavor.
Wme.
Wme owns UFC.
Now I'm aware of the shore.
That's what.
That's the only thing that was his
decision was his decision.
He goes,
I'm going to let we agreed to this.
It was in our contracts.
One time thing.
I'll never do it again.
I thought,
God damn,
that is so.
She must've put it in the contract.
She must've said,
this is what I want to do.
I don't want to talk to any media.
I just want to go to red flag.
Do you not have connor did it?
I mean,
connor doesn't have the choice coming
into connor said it,
but if connor did it,
have connor said,
fuck all this fucking media.
I'm going to.
I'm going to train.
He would never do that.
If he did,
I'd have no problem.
Red flagged out to anyone involved at
all.
Dana this say it's all good.
Don't do anything.
Here's the thing.
She goes out,
she goes out,
grabs hold of Man Nunez,
flips her on her head.
Semi unconscious,
catches her in an arm bar.
She's the new champ and 35 seconds.
You're not saying this.
I disagree.
Oh,
you wouldn't say there's a red flag.
If she went out and dominated it and
then got an arm bar in the first round,
you would definitely not say that.
Skipping the media is a red flag,
so then she'll only saying it because
this is like armchair quarterbacking.
It's not though,
because that says a red flag before this
because if she.
So she did interviews afterwards.
Let's say she went out the dominator in
a minute submitted and then she did
interviews afterwards.
That's a little different.
You know what I'm saying?
Because she just said I'm not doing any
meat at all.
Even post post.
Well she doesn't want to talk after
that.
I mean why would you want the other
thing in the whole cell on this?
Was she serious?
Now she.
Oh my God.
She's focused knowing that you serious
now the whole thing.
The whole thing was like this big
obvious marketing perspective,
like a promotional Hollywood
perspective.
Like they had the movie,
which is a really good guy.
He pumped up like that whole thing about
her coming back and they lift up the
garage doors,
see are working out really hard and it's
what they did is they created a great
hype piece.
You know,
if you're in the Ronda Rousey business.
Exactly.
Amanda Nunez going,
what exactly did you get?
My best was the best.
Was there a picture of promoting this
UFC and there's a picture of Ronda and
her fight.
Karen Ronda and the street clothes goes.
She's back to oh seven.
It's like,
fuck man.
What about Amanda?
When I say in this crazy mixture,
who did that picture that he was an
official UFC,
UFC kind of a social media post.
Wow.
It's crazy man,
because now what do you do?
It's also crazy because it's crazy for a
marketing perspective.
I mean a lot of people thought that
Rhonda was going to win a lot of people.
I was 100 percent.
Who the fuck knows me too?
That's exactly how I felt when I was
watching that fight play out.
I was like,
who the fuck knows?
I mean,
you could see.
Look,
Rhonda looked like she was in amazing
shape.
You think about the things that Ron has
been able to do in the past to like
Sarah Mcmahon,
you would think,
well maybe she ties her up in a clench.
Blasts or the need of the body flips her
on her back and arm bars or who the fuck
knows if she gets you on the ground?
Her arm bar technique is outstanding.
It's just some of the best,
if not the best I've ever seen that that
could have happened,
but it was so.
Who the fuck knows?
But the moment she got hit,
she's not moving her head at all.
She's standing straight up in the air
and then I see her legs get close
together and that's when you know
someone's really hurt when someone gets
lit up and then they start moving,
but their legs are too close together.
She's not working right.
It's not like they kind of know what to
do,
but it's just not.
They're not their balances and good.
There was no head movement.
She was probably hurt with like the
second or third punch that Amanda hit
her with.
She was probably on Queer Street,
woke her up.
She didn't know where she was until she
got it.
Joe,
look at that when she got hit.
When you go,
Ooh,
she's hurt.
She's hurt.
Look at her face and you even said it
yourself.
She threw up and kick.
She threw some kicks to try to keep
Amanda off.
I think she didn't realize.
I think when Amanda Hits Girls,
they just go,
Holy Shit.
Yup.
But what else would you.
What else would you expect in that?
You know what I'm saying,
like you don't realize to get hit,
but you hear all the criticism.
Now have a Edmond who's obviously a
terrible coach,
but take that out of it.
If if you bring a horse to water,
you can't drink,
there's nothing else you can do.
So if mentally she doesn't want to be in
there,
do you think we didn't want to be in
there?
It didn't look like the same tenacity
that were used to seeing challenged.
Super tenacious until she got cracked.
Joe Is 44 seconds when more than that
First Jab.
She got hurt with a right hand.
Maybe 10:50.
We didn't watch the whole fight fight.
It's 47 seconds.
Go.
You good?
Uh,
it's on youtube.
It's everywhere.
Doesn't matter.
Fighters before,
like,
what do you think it is?
I don't understand why.
Why are you even saying this?
You see that she got hit and she,
she got hurt and you've been hitting
hurt before.
Know what happens.
You just don't know what the fuck's
going on.
Correct.
I think however that jab put her lights
out.
It wasn't just a Jap.
Did she hit her with a Jap that landed
the first one?
She went into Cape closed desk.
First Jab landed,
but then she got hit with many punches.
I don't understand why you're confused
as to the result.
I mean she got hit by the biggest power
puncher in 135 pound division by far.
There's not a single girl in that
division that punches like Amanda does.
I agree with that,
but not that it wasn't a right hand
right away.
Yes it was.
It was a jab right away,
but a right hand right after that,
once,
once run to try to close the distance
was 40 seconds of Amanda Punching Rhonda
in the face until Rhonda would out like
the idea that some.
Something's confusing that she didn't
look like she wanted to be there.
She was hurt multiple times in those
exchanges.
I just don't.
I think we're doing a lot of armchair
quarterbacking,
right?
Who the fuck knows what was going on?
Know what you're speculating whether or
not she wanted to be there after she got
hit.
The problem is she might've been just
rocked and there's also the reality that
she was knocked out fucking cold a year
ago and it was a bad beating and then a
vicious head kick and there was
something about those Goddamn neck
kicks.
Man.
There's something about when when
someone shins you in the neck,
like she got shin and your whole body
just goes limp.
You're doing so much damage in there,
but she had a 411 days off.
That's nice.
I think it was just bad strategy.
It's really simple.
It's just the strategy was not good as
possible to all those things.
Look,
I was the one who said like way early
on,
I think Amanda is our most dangerous
challenge because Amanda hits so fucking
heart after she starts Sara Mcmahon and
when she,
when she was beaten up,
Michelle was like,
Jesus said she punches harder than
anybody in that division.
She's got like dangerous weapons with
her hands,
but I think I really think there's a lot
of people that get killed like that and
they are never the same again.
They can't absorb a shot anymore.
And then also in your brain.
According to chocolate Delhi he was
telling me about it like,
because chuck was so tough that he would
like just fucking use his chin,
sort of like Linacre does.
Like it's part of his defense,
like knowing that he can absorb shots
and after a while his brain was like,
hey man,
fuck you.
Like his brain was just like,
we're not going to do this,
and yeah,
just shuts off early.
I also think tech to you,
there's a certain level where they're,
where they're that great and you look at
it like a tiger woods or Mike Tyson.
When that foundation get the little
shaky,
there's just never the same.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's just never.
They're like,
I'm not God's gift to the use.
Exactly.
MMA gods don't give a shit.
Exactly,
and then like we said,
even if she was undefeated and she
fought,
Nunez Nunez going to give her a problem
because if you watched like the Misha
tate fight me should take.
Like,
even though she beat me,
she would take twice me,
she'd take,
gave her a hard time.
There was some good scrambles and be
state hitter with some punches.
If Amanda Hits You with punches like
that,
you're fuck.
You can't make mistakes.
You're in trouble.
Yeah.
She's like a lot of ways.
It's like a female rumble and that she
might not be able to close the show with
one shot like rumble can,
but if you make mistakes,
you get stung so bad and you see it with
Sara mcmann fights.
A perfect example,
she cracked Sarah with a right hand.
You see her.
Her whole face is like,
what the f?
Like nobody hits them like that.
Nobody and she's long.
Amanda catches you on the end of those
punches too.
She.
She's great at distance.
I also think that the game is evolving
so fast.
Where Amanda,
all she cares about is being champ.
All she does is trained.
That's the only thing she gives a fuck
about.
I think we saw the same thing in the
dominant coups,
cody garbrandt fight.
All cody wants to do is be champ.
Dominic's doing analyst work for.
So I think there's,
there's this kind of change of hands
right now where you're seeing these guys
who are,
they're all in and that's what you have
to do to be in this game this day and
age.
Guys are too good there too.
Good.
And I think you're dead right?
I think you're dead right about that.
Oh,
here we go.
We'll watch the whole thing live.
Now.
Give us some volume.
Young Jamie.
So here it is.
So that jab landed with five second.
This jab right there.
Watch this.
She stopped her right there.
Yeah.
See,
so she's stunning.
Ten seconds in,
we're at four.
Forty three were 15 seconds in and she's
already.
She's fucked right there.
She's fuck.
That was a super hard and this is bad to
watch.
It's real hard to boom to the body to.
She ripped that shot to the body.
So like the idea that she didn't want to
be there 10 seconds into the fight,
she didn't know what the fuck was going.
Oh,
they're left right hand,
right hand behind it.
This is horrific,
man.
It's tough.
Boom,
boom.
God Damn.
Great stoppage.
But God damn Amanda Nunez as good.
She put a finger up to her mouth,
walked right up to Edmond,
looked at show gangster.
You know,
she's in another dimension.
Got No doubt about it.
You just know about.
She's tough.
And also she's got that thick old neck
that helps the got long Amanda's arms
and she's great at keeping distance,
not crowding herself.
Amanda has a wide shoulders and that
helps too.
And then long arms as well and she's got
awesome distance man.
Her,
her ability to catch you at the very
back of the punches for all the power is
because if you're punching someone and
you want to eat them here,
but they just move forward a foot,
you lose.
You lose like 90 percent of your power.
Different game.
Do you think Amanda can fight guys that
went 35?
Well,
bad guys,
good guys.
No trains with super high level guys
like she's not going to be Tj dillashaw
on top 10 now it's changed now man.
People,
I think if you asked them that same
question three or four years ago would
have a different answer,
but like that division is so stacked
now.
It's like one.
One 35 first opened up.
It was in the UFC was.
There wasn't as many guys that would
that elite.
He know there's like even watch the guys
who were really good improve like you
saw the cody fight where he was fucking
fantastic against dominick goddamn good
to Tj.
Look against Linacre.
Completely known five linacre nullify
them when a girl.
He's like one of the best examples of a
guy with absolutely freakish physical
attributes of fucking iron jaw,
iron.
John never even seen the guy get hurt.
He gets hit by everybody,
gets head kicked,
he gets punched.
Rob said he hit him with the hardest
punch he ever hit anybody with his life
and he goes,
he didn't even knowledge that he hit
him.
He just walked right forward.
He's and he hit him with a body shot.
Felt like you get hit by a car.
He didn't look like that Linacre.
I don't think that same linacre showed
up on Saturday or Friday and teaching
all of them.
He didn't have a chance,
but Lynika was very hesitant and I think
it's because of PJ's,
the way he was fighting them with the
faith that take downs,
the kicks and thrown that,
that head kick to the body kick,
but he was very tentative.
He got,
he got out beat.
You throw them in the truck.
Almost had them in a capsule.
I thought he was gonna.
Go for the twister.
I was like,
oh my God,
if he goes to the twister,
but he got went to the capsize it,
but I'm like,
I looked it up.
Like he's not going to tap to that.
It's just pay a stomp.
He needed to stomp down.
Tj looked amazing.
Amazing.
Yeah.
And the timing and those takedowns like
lightning bolts,
like it looks like he's throwing a punch
and he's underneath Ya.
Just so nasty.
So fast,
man.
But God damn cody Garbrandt the fuck God
damn.
I'll admit I.
I said I think cody's going to be champ.
Just not just not yet.
He's going to be your champ,
but he's not ready for dom yet.
No opening round was like,
what the fuck?
He's so busy mimic.
He's doing break dancing.
He's doing push ups and shit.
He fucked with Dominic's head and that
was one of the things that I was
thinking was like,
this kid's been in a lot of street
fights,
like I don't know if this trash talk is
going to work on him the way it works on
other guys.
Like he said,
he was fine in there like I asked them,
but it's like I liked that.
He goes,
I feel calm.
I know I can stay calm when that's going
on.
And I think he's just like this young
hungry dude who,
he took it personal and a lot of guys
get real emotional and I was worried
that cody come out super emotional,
just get like taken down.
Just real emotional,
like A.
Although David against me Gregor,
we're just forgets about his technique
and rushes and gets marked.
But dude,
he just took all that and the best
performance.
I mean,
can you name another performance like
that where a guy he remembered he was
even number one contenders,
five or six in the world that he was
eight.
Was He a.
I thought I moved to six maybe,
but that might have been some
shenanigans.
Just who knows that the cheeto finger
rankings but still motherfucker went
from five,
six rank number one.
I'm like,
that's a big strategy.
Handily.
It wasn't a Thompson one round.
Yeah.
And,
and cody dropped him,
heard him.
We,
we don't,
we still don't exactly know where the
cut came from.
Some people were saying it came from a
punch.
I heard people say online say came from
a Kyc,
definitely not drop,
but the guys in the trucks that it was a
headbutt truck boys were off because I
heard when they said that,
I'm like,
what the fuck are they watch?
Yeah,
they,
uh,
pulled it up for me,
but it's hard.
See,
while the fights going on,
they'll do that and I'll tell me it's a
headbutt and see I have two monitors in
front of me.
I've one right here and then I've won
over the side and they'll say like,
look on monitor be,
and then they'll show it to me,
but I can't really.
It's hard for me to do that while I'm
watching the actual fight,
you know?
So they'll show it to me and I usually,
I just take their word for it,
but occasionally I think in the replay
that they showed and maybe they saw
different and it show the correct one
three play that they showed it was
definitely wasn't a headbutt well,
they definitely did collide heads for
sure for sure.
And so who knows?
It was hard to tell,
but who gives a fuck either.
It was a big ass cut,
big ass cut on Dom's eyebrow and he got
drunk.
How good is dominick?
Cruz took a punch to but he gets in,
he gets cracked,
his legs go stiff.
He goes down and a couple of times cody
like acted almost like you wasn't going
to follow him to the ground and and beat
on them on the ground and almost acted
like he was done.
He was like calling them up or like a
Mark Hunt kind of walk off caleb better
get on them.
Didn't even,
didn't even make an attempt to it.
Well maybe he doesn't want to have
anything to do with the ground.
Maybe he feels like that's where dominic
might have a chance to shut down their
son.
I don't know what dominick Cruz wanting
to punish them to.
Maybe just how many crews have any
submissions?
Dominick Cruz is really good on the
ground.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Record.
Does he have any submission?
Yeah,
he has some missions for usually from
guillotines though.
Back in the day was his Jujitsu is
really good.
Trust me.
No,
no,
no.
He's a black belt for sure.
I've seen him compete in tournaments and
uh,
any wrestled as well.
He's a wrestler for a guy not to go down
in his guard.
That's some shit.
That's like some conor Mcgregor Diaz
Shit were like,
I just don't want.
I can lose two easily down there.
Well,
I mean it might not have been that at
all.
It might have been even more simple.
That's a lost jamie naked.
Yeah.
So he's got a rear naked there.
He's got.
So he lost to a.
he's got one room naked guard.
You're right.
Well who knows,
so you don't,
you still,
you don't know what he could do.
But the bottom line was,
cody wanted to keep the fight standing.
Can you just want to punish him and hit
him so hard?
That might've thought the fight was
over.
He,
he seemed to have the answer for
Dominic.
I mean at least it worked for cody
wasn't or wasn't not.
I'm no stryker that he made dominant
come to him and it's different when.
Correct.
Is that what it was?
Well,
sort of,
but it's also you got to give credit to
his teams.
He,
Justin Buchholz and those guys had been
imitating.
They fought dom so many times,
six times and imitate his movements so
they can mimic his shit.
So when they're sparring,
they do that,
that fake stuff that like false start
because dom does this thing where false
starts and then he'd start and you never
know which one's going to be a kick,
which I could see a lot of like,
like patterns at dom throws up.
So they figured out how to do that and
they mimicked and they watched him so
many times that they can get it down to
a t and cody didn't bind into the
faints.
You'll just like,
come on,
if you're going to come on,
come in within this range,
and he kept baiting him and they'd make
it count.
Yeah.
The bottom line is if his brain's not
confused and he just knows that in these
exchanges,
dom's going to be there and he's going
to do some,
you know,
he's got some really unpredictable
movement.
Dom does,
but he does like a bunch of things a
lot.
And then commits.
Yeah.
And so he timed those things and caught
them with some fucking vicious punches,
man.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
he wasn't like dom fights a lot of guys
and they're like,
what the fuck did that?
Chris Tucker movie gets hit in the face.
That guy,
which one y'all kicked me and you don't
know where it's coming from,
but he just,
uh,
he just garbage and just never bought
it.
I'm thinking,
wait for you to commit.
You can do all that jazz and I'm just
going to wait right here.
It's also a guy's been boxed.
And when he was real young talking about
last night.
Yeah,
it was 32 and two amateur record.
You look at that,
but in the UFC compared to other
fighters that boxing comes in,
this huge.
He was coaching.
He was.
Cody was catching dominick Cruz on the
way out.
[inaudible],
which that's a lot of people don't catch
them on the way and never see it.
No,
he was catching them on the way up and
the speed and precision of punching
power.
Glorious for five rounds and then people
forget.
Cody in high school,
he,
I think he was first team all state out
of Ohio,
which is a big deal out there.
He had scholarships,
played division one or I'm sorry,
compete in Division One.
Wrestling was like,
Nah,
I'm just going to fight professionally
full time.
That's what kind of stud you're dealing
with.
His uncle was an alternate for the
Olympic boxing team,
so I mean he comes from a long line of
just savages to pretty crazy.
Yeah.
This his countdown piece was pretty
amazing.
I,
I didn't see it.
I wish that a fighter's appreciate the
science of boxing more.
When GSP
one of those fights he trained with
Freddie Roach and it came back with that
Fucking Jab.
It made waves,
but a lot of people didn't copy that.
Arloski did.
First it was like,
Nah,
let's just go boom.
You know,
he's like,
Holy Amanda Nunez boxing trainer is
Howard Davis,
his son.
Okay.
And American top team.
So she's,
I don't know why people don't
incorporate it that much.
More so much to learn.
You said there's three levels of
striking pretty much in the UFC.
You know,
we had a discussion last night when,
when,
uh,
the Jujitsu Guy,
when 70 came in,
you know,
he came in and he was a great Jujitsu
guy.
He wanted a,
what's his name,
the guy that triangle jail from the top.
Damien.
Damien Maia.
That guy came in.
He went the first couple of matches
Jujitsu.
Then somebody told him he was a boxer.
He started getting lit up and it
happened.
He's fucking back to just grab your leg
and it's all under Rhonda.
100 percent.
Rhonda just said,
okay,
I'm gonna.
Take a year off.
Go to the Olympic wrestling a facility
wherever.
Just focus on wrestling.
Still work on your striking.
Go with Duane Ludwig.
That would be awesome.
Or,
or Rafael Cordeiro mix it up,
you know what I mean?
You've got to change shit up now
obviously.
Um,
but wrestling should be the focus.
When you see a Rhonda Rousey Promo,
you shouldn't see her getting mets.
You should see her shooting,
getting the clench.
Double leg,
take down singles.
It should be wrestling every day.
Twice a day for.
But think about her camp,
her whole camp.
It's just a boxing gym.
Those are head coaches,
a boxing coach.
So they want her to be this boxer.
People sold her as the next Mike Tyson.
So you have all that come in.
And she was Merkin girls.
Remember I was on board till I'm like
damn,
are striking.
She's not going to bitches out.
Then you start to the level.
It's like the devil she's knocking them
out at.
Yeah.
But,
but,
but I,
I think the media and a lot of people
are like,
Dang she,
she's a knockout artists.
So you hear those in her canceling your
knockout artists.
You can strike with anyone.
Right.
And her coach like,
look,
that was always the case.
You remember when Gerald fought in the
UFC?
It was always the case when Gerald is a.
was he a black male back then or brown
belt?
It was a brown belt.
Really Good Jujitsu guy though,
but his fucking striking coach had him
convinced that he was a boxer.
He's like,
you're going to go out there and get a
kick,
and I remember Eddie and I would train
them and watch them hit the bag and hit
the meds and stuff,
and I was like,
man,
there are some scary guys in the UFC.
And he got a real scary one.
And Josh Thompson,
Josh Thompson was like,
Yep,
none of that deck I take.
No,
no,
it wasn't.
Didn't go down like that and ain't got
nothing happening.
No.
What ended up happening as Gerald's
Jujitsu jokes treatment as we're talking
about his.
He was my first student,
my first before 10th planet.
I was teaching Jujitsu to a guy named
Gerald Street and he was a blue belt at
the time and I brought them up,
shut him up.
He got really good at the twister,
really good at rubber guard,
rubber.
He first meet Hook,
rubber guard,
triangle and MMA history.
Uh,
in a gladiator challenge show,
he was kicking ass and then he fired
John Silva in England,
in London and it was a spectacular
match.
A Joe showed that fight to,
uh,
Dana White.
Dana white game was shot game.
Josh Thompson.
Boom,
right off the bat he started,
he started working more with pie with
this,
this Muay Thai coach,
and it was six months.
He was trying to six months with them.
Right.
And you'd been doing any.
He wrestled in high school as well.
So He'd been grappling a total at that
point.
Joey breeding into the mic.
I'm hearing some for sure Joe.
I'm was confused in my head too worried.
Right.
But anyways,
so anyway,
so he and,
and it's an interesting point.
I was just thinking about this.
It's the exact same thing.
It's when I'm,
when I'm striking like let's say I got,
I'm a striker,
Muy Thai came in and he'd been doing
more type for 10 years and he wanted to
learn the ground and he was doing mma.
He's already fighting MMA.
It comes up a lot.
I'm going to show them Jujitsu.
I'm going to be in this corner,
I'm not going to be telling him to take
his ass down and work up into Jitsu,
pull guard.
I'm like,
you just.
It has been six months this relaxed,
but what I was getting involved,
but I want to see is that dude when with
his tie and it gives me another fight to
get his Jujitsu and again,
the longer that you.
The jujitsu in my eyes,
the batter we,
whew.
We got away with another one.
Now we have another four or five months
to work on the Jujitsu pointed way of
looking at it,
but there's a lot of stars out.
There's a lot of strikers striking
coaches out there that will take some
grappler in,
teach them striking for six months and
then a corner him in an mma fight and
like instruct him to stand with this
amount of.
Pull the guy to the side say,
dude,
don't listen to this guy.
You're not standing.
Do you remember what he said?
You know how many times I had to say
that up?
Like my guys,
I go,
tell him,
listen to this motherfucker.
He's taking this motherfucker even came
out.
Remember what he said.
Do you remember what he said to them?
Was Ready?
Yes.
In six months instead was Bangkok.
Greg is going to go out there,
so this is what ends up happening
luckily,
but you know what?
It it.
It was a.
It was a good thing.
It's a good thing because this is what
happened.
Is He Adam,
so believing that he was Bangkok ready
after six months of Moitai that when he
did the walkout in the UFC,
he came out with a more time to have a,
a,
a bicep bracelets or whatever,
the tigard dancing and doing the time.
He was in the octagon and did you know
he went around the octagon and blessed.
Yes.
Doing that through and then Josh
Thompson sitting there and I talked to
Josh Thompson since then.
Josh Thompson wrestled in high school
and he's a really good striker.
He was fucking up people off his back.
He was triangling people.
We knew all about Josh Thompson.
Gerald was not.
He was not in the best frame of mind for
that fight,
you know?
I mean,
because Josh Thompson was a fucking
killer back then.
He was a kid.
Well,
he was in his prime back then.
That was josh when he was.
He was one of the top,
like five or six guys in the division.
UFC got rid of the 155 pound division.
It was him and Eve Edwards.
Yeah.
Eve Edwards knocked him out.
I was like,
Eve Edwards became the uncrowned king.
So this is what happened.
So luckily,
and this is according to Josh Thompson
told me,
Josh goes,
dude,
I was so worried about a standing stop
that when we saw the fight,
my whole thing was how do we know the
whole.
The whole thing was for sure Josh
Thompson is not going to want to go to
the ground with Gerald.
That's where all this good shit is.
He's fucking people up and NMA.
All his fights up until the USC was
fucking people up with the Jujitsu.
So how are we going to get the fight to
the ground?
We were thinking about pulling.
How elaborate a unorthodox Cardpool,
how are we going to do it?
That's what I was thinking like six
months.
I go,
I know he thinks he's Bangkok.
Right?
That's six months,
man.
Thank you.
So,
so,
so.
So Josh takes him down and I was sitting
there thinking,
what the fuck thing?
He takes a general dental because he's
so worried about his tie and Gerald d
right away throws up a hell fire with
this guard.
He threw a lot of heat.
It was pretty bad ass to see,
but at the end of the day,
first he almost had him in an arm bar.
Josh pulls out and then there's like a
scramble on the ground.
Gerald ghost for a leg lock because he
finally pulls out of his garden.
Then general who was really good at like
locks and he went for a leg lock and
then Josh Thompson hit him like in the
back of the head and knocked him out.
Killer.
That was one of those.
Yeah.
That was one of those going,
you know,
going into a box is risky.
What started this all off?
Bolded.
Those coaches,
coaches get these fucking people
convinced that there's try killer in one
particular every camp though,
because in every campus,
especially if you have like a superstar
camp and it does come from my own
personal experience,
you have a superstar wrestling coach,
boxing coach,
Jujitsu coach,
you know you're spending your time with
them.
They want to see you win with,
with their shit.
Yes.
Even coaches get tossed them off.
The W should be number fucking war.
It's nice when they win with some shit
of course,
like fucked up.
Like you showed me that shit.
That's always good,
but it's all about the Goddamn w.
that's number one.
You gotTa have like a head coach.
You got to have a head coach that's not
a striking coast.
How'd you like a head coach?
Matt Hume as a head coach.
You know like when he works with Dj,
they do everything,
you know,
they work on submissions together,
spar together.
He worked,
they work on all these different
techniques and it's total technique and
tactics oriented conversations in how
many other though in the world?
Like five one.
His hat is honestly this like in my
mind,
it's like he,
if he's not number one,
it's him and for us a hobby,
but I count two that can do it all,
that really
know the game in and out.
Can do a game plan from standing to
restroom to grapple.
Yeah,
I mean I think the one guy might be
better for you.
One guy might be better for the other,
but those are the.
Those are the top dogs too because
there's such wizards on the ground are
wizards to it and they.
They could physically do it too.
That's like a big part of it and plus
they know that transition.
Like sometimes if you go to a pure
Jujitsu guy,
he's like,
dude,
this isn't gonna work.
If I commit both hands this,
I'm going to blast in the face.
Do you remember what George Greer Gel
like?
He was a black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu
back when there was very few black
belts,
but then he became.
He wanted to stand and bang with
everybody and that was his thing.
Yeah.
Became this thing standing in banging
and that's.
That happens so often.
It's,
it's so crazy and it's so rare that a
guy comes back and figures it out.
Like Damien Maia House.
Damien Maia tried it that way for
awhile.
Yup.
You got sucked into it and they figured
they ended up with Rhonda.
Should they took it to what says
expression.
You go to the dance or what took you to
the express?
I know what happens is a lot of early,
I show a lot of high level Jujitsu guys
come into the UFC that the hands a Mensa
mense yeah.
It's like a three striking and they
never evolved to that.
Now fucking striking is evolving quick,
quick.
You know,
it used to be that the only guys,
the only black belts that got to the UFC
were like the guys that were only
dedicated their lives to.
Did you get to.
They just started learning and striking.
You can tell upon,
you can tell like,
holy shit,
they're just trying to fucking get some
kind of.
It's obvious,
but now with,
there's so many goddamn black belts in
Brazil now that it's not about.
It's all about,
you know,
here's,
here's 100 black belts in the camp.
We're only going to take the best
strikers.
Like the fierce ones.
You know the guy,
the days of pure Jujitsu guys coming out
and looking like this,
that there are long gone now.
You can't,
you can't get,
get through the minor leagues.
Well,
in a way like that.
Your attitude is like,
I got this
right.
Like my forestry isn't combat.
I didn't write shit.
I would just go up on stage and do that
in New York.
Shit to live in.
Yeah.
It was 50 slash 50.
What do you do for a living?
You do this.
I got really good at it,
but I couldn't make a living doing that.
If I'm bombing,
I could fall back to that shit and rock
the house.
I don't work that muscle anymore.
Do you know what I'm saying?
When I first started comedy,
I had to go on stage every Tuesday and
further the same fucking people.
So you had to write a new five minutes.
For two years I did that.
There was some weeks I couldn't do it,
so I just decided just to improvise.
I got so good at improvising and by the
time I got to Seattle and started
featuring,
I was really good improvised.
So what?
What are you saying about how does this
equate to fighting?
I don't improvise no more because I got
it.
When you first met me at the store 15
years ago,
I would go onstage and do seven minutes
of material and the rest of it is
improvised.
I thought it was cool.
Right?
They will sheet and when it works it
works.
When it doesn't work,
but I'm pretty good at it.
I could really improvise.
Pretty good.
Do I still do it today?
No,
because you have to evolve.
I could fall back on the dog.
I could fall back on my wrestling.
That's my wrestling.
That's my pedigree.
When me and you will feel when I call
you and I make you laugh on the phone,
it's like that.
I didn't call you with a script when I
call you.
I mean you're talking about something
that's not a script.
That's me.
And you drive and getting excited,
right?
I got that pedigree.
I could rock that pedigree,
but that pedigree isn't going to take me
to the next level.
You have to sit and you have to write
and you have to evolve different things.
So I think that when I'm a wrestler,
okay,
I'm a black belt in Jujitsu.
I've been doing this since I was 18.
I'm 31 now.
I've won Abu Dhabi.
Dubai,
Abu Dhabi?
No,
GIP and Americans.
I got this.
I got these.
Yeah,
like two different styles of winters.
There's the all around the guy like Dj
and then there's a guy like Anderson
Silva that really,
I mean he might submit people,
but it's so rare.
And when he submitted chell center,
it's almost like Chael Sonnen.
He gave it to him.
I mean that,
that,
that fucking armbar triangle combination
wasn't even locked in.
It wasn't even locked in.
I mean it was,
uh,
it was kinda over the calf a little.
It wasn't clamped down.
I mean maybe chair was so exhausted that
he had a tap.
But honestly,
I mean if you asked him,
he was.
He was pretty honest about having mental
breakdowns in fights.
He did it with a polo female members.
Same thing on the Anderson Silva fight
though.
You said going in,
he and he goes,
I know I'm gonna get submitted.
I'm get submitted.
So when he was taking down,
he's in this guide for like three
minutes.
He's going,
it's just a matter of time.
He's going to catch me.
He's going to catch it again.
So again,
to understand this in silver.
Well,
he had been submitted a few times in
fights that he was winning.
The whole thing is.
It's weird,
but my point is,
Anderson's never been like a great
Jujitsu guy.
He's a black belt.
Tapped out Dan Henderson,
wherever that will beat the fuck out of
him before.
But he.
It was a beautiful tape was.
That is true.
He did get his back and choking him out.
Disagree with you on that triangle.
That triangle was legitimate.
Let's look at it.
But a trial versus a Anderson Silva
Triangle,
if I remember correctly,
it wasn't fully locked in.
There was a little bit of space.
It doesn't have to be fully felt like.
It depends on how much you're squeezing
it lead curling's true end.
He has long legs,
so due to.
That's true.
Good point.
To Joe's point is exhausted guy,
but my point is Anderson Silva is a
goddamn specialist.
His specialty is more tie in,
especially as striking.
When you look at Anderson Silva's
highlight reels,
is that front kick to the face on
Vittorio?
It's that fucking need of the body down
Stephen Bond and that's his gift.
I care.
So here it is them at this point.
This is a gel at a beautiful double,
didn't he?
He drove it so hard on that double.
He takes him down.
Should he fights in a couple of.
This is the fourth round.
[inaudible].
Let's go to the end of the flight.
Okay,
let's see this.
This we're child stands up and sits
back.
That's tight as fuck dude.
Let me see.
That's tight as fuck.
That's titus as a lot tighter than I
thought.
Well,
when he finally got the arms are opened
up the line because he looked like he
was about to swing the leg.
Oh,
I haven't seen that in awhile.
Go back then.
I'm getting there.
It's tight right there.
That's tight.
I take it back.
Chill.
When he,
right when he gets the arm is.
That's when he opens up.
Now it's a different thing now.
It's an arm bar.
Yep,
that's right.
So my point being like the best guys at
one particular thing are pretty rare,
like the guys like an Anderson that is
just so elite at striking that nobody
wants to strike with them or it got like
Damien Maia solely to Jujitsu that he
makes guys like Carlos Condit look like
they have no idea what they're doing.
He gets you on the ground and it makes
you a little white pill.
But so there's that kind of guy that
could do that.
Or there's a guy like mighty mouse,
mighty mouse.
Although he's got really good
submissions,
you're not going to see that style and
he's not going to be able to submit the
best Jujitsu guys in the world.
One hundred 25 pounds,
most likely in a Jew Jitsu match.
Damien Maia probably could,
you know Damien Maia has the potential
to beat pretty much anybody he rolls
with on the Mat and an actual straight
up Jujitsu match.
So it's,
you have two different styles you have
like that style of winter which has
never won the title and there's only a
few guys like Anderson that have,
you know,
and,
and Anderson in all due fairness,
he wanted like what in 2005 was that
when Anderson somewhere around there in
the UFC.
That's a lot.
That's done.
Might as well be 30 years ago.
It's a totally different class of
fighter.
This evolution of the game is so fast.
Like four years ago,
we're in leather helmets.
Like I would love to watch tyron woodley
versus Demian Maia.
Love it.
I would love to watch it.
That would be incredible.
That to me is maybe one of the most
interesting fights on the horizon for me
so far.
Damien Maia has been able to take down
wrestlers that he's been able to take
them all down like easy and just the
beautiful technique and a black kid do
that.
That would lead.
You got to go.
No,
you got to go through the storm.
The storm of fucking meteors coming your
way.
The Woodley drops on you because he's
the most dangerous in that first round
when you're trying to take him down,
you're closing the distance on them and
you haven't figured out how fast he is
yet because he's not.
He doesn't hit hard.
He's fucking fast.
I saw some,
uh,
just rumor,
I'm sure.
But a big thing was talking about it.
Him and Woodley agreeing to a super fund
at one 80.
Really?
Bisbee and Woodley.
When did they agree to this?
Uh,
I was talking to my brother.
He was like,
you see woodland bisbing want to do like
cathaway that one 80.
I'm like,
that's an interesting fight.
First of all,
can bisping make that healthy?
That's what I was thinking because
five's the tough cut for him.
Remember when he used to fight two?
Oh,
one,
two.
Oh,
five.
Yup.
Wow,
that's an interesting fight.
Well,
I think what,
what would the want is that big payday?
He's like,
let's.
Yeah,
I mean he's campaigning for it.
Look at this.
Mike Bisbee and tyrone Woodley.
Agree to catch weight about this is
legit.
So it just happened today on the
Internet.
What is the name of the um,
the Internet low kick MMA.com.
Interesting.
Let's banks.
Instagram is very interesting.
Very interesting.
So gangster weight as Jill Sullivan
calls it.
Yeah,
I like it.
But like to your point will,
he just wants a big fight for lucrative
payday.
He wants the biggest thing possible to
get paid.
Yeah.
Smart.
That's the name of the game.
Yeah.
And you know,
an Anderson back.
Uh,
and that has been still been calling for
a rematch with bisbing too because his
fight with bisping so fucking close in
England,
he feels like he beat him.
That was one of the craziest situations.
He hits him with that flying knee.
Awesome.
I mean,
bisping was out,
he went out,
he dropped and Anderson does a walk off
Kale and they go,
Eh,
not so quick.
It was so weird.
So weird.
Oh,
why does that make get a video of that?
Because remember [inaudible] being takes
a break because his mouthpiece falls out
and he's like talking to the ref and
Nancy goes,
oh,
that's right.
That's right.
He,
he was trying to get the referees
attention and Anderson Flying Nita and
the ref like coming into stop it then.
So did that flying knee.
That's why the ref was like,
hold up.
No,
that doesn't look at that.
That's very weird.
Stitching box his fucking face off.
Like he's saying something.
He's herb dean.
Look,
he's like right there,
right there.
Boom.
Oh Jesus.
That was also the end of the round two,
right?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Jesus,
look at this again.
He's like,
Hey,
let me get my mouthpiece.
Oh Shit.
Oh boy.
So look at this.
Boom.
That is such a crazy drop to the way you
get hit thrown the knee.
Regardless whether he looked to the side
or not,
I think he would have thrown it
regardless and it wasn't like bisbing
put his hands down.
He looked over,
but he was still covered up.
Here's the moment that I think he was a
little distracted there for sure.
Here's the crazy thing.
Pittsburgh comes back and wins that
fucking fight.
Face off.
How's you when that actually comes out
that I think that was the third round,
right?
He comes out that fourth round and I
knocked his his face off crazy.
Like a kangaroo crazy recovery.
That means unbelieved cardiovert insane.
Yeah.
Because most people get hit like that.
That's it.
I mean his body shut off and he dropped.
No,
the power of give us a second June and
we're back.
Partially blind in one eye or
completely.
Partially.
Yeah,
but he could still see.
He can see enough where they let them
fight.
Yeah.
I mean he does those dye tests.
They have to do.
I test.
Apparently what they did is they put
some kind of oil in his eye and that oil
like protects his retina somehow or
another and that's why it looks so crazy
and once he's done fighting then they'll
fix it.
But the problem is like if he gets it
fixed now and then he goes and fights
again and tears it even worse.
And then the other thing is the more
time he waits more advanced,
all the stem cell shit is getting.
Like they,
they brought someone's vision back with
stem cells.
Sign guy.
Someone was blind and they injected stem
cells and this guy's eye and brought his
vision back then.
And that's today,
2017.
What's it gonna be like five,
six,
seven years down the line and be retired
by then?
I would will be,
be retired three or four.
I mean I think he's 39 now,
right?
Michael?
Uh,
yeah.
I might not be that old.
I might be.
I might be up to 36.
You might be 37,
36,
37,
37.
I don't think he has three years left.
Well,
he might look so fucking game,
you know,
Michael Bisping does not have any
extraordinary physical attributes and
not that he's not a great athlete.
He certainly is not.
He's done a very good fighter.
He's certainly as cardio.
But if you look at a guy like rumble,
extraordinary physical attributes,
John Linacre,
well Michael Bisping has is just
toughness.
Just game as fuck.
Toughness,
knock them out.
He comes back and he just keeps coming
back.
There's was no quit.
He doesn't know any of this.
Great Cardio is no quit.
Amazing Cardio.
Ryan Parson says in the gym,
he said he's never seen a guy that hates
getting tapped and hates losing
exchanges more.
I've never seen anything like it.
Even even just,
you know,
you do,
you like your normal warm up.
Like if you're doing an under hook,
just he's going 100 percent nonstop,
like slow down.
Um,
the title man,
while I'm fucking title better and
better even watch him improve.
Fight to fight.
Look at his boxing.
His boxing is ridiculous.
Man.
Lost Innocence Silva knocked out.
Luke rockhold,
Luke rockhold disdainful in that fight.
Like like,
come on man,
what are you going to do?
Yeah,
he's busy.
It's show up for that flood.
Yeah.
He was disdainful that that was his
challenge and he got burned.
He got murked.
Oh.
And bisbing was shooting triple x 19 and
Toronto is like,
Huh,
yeah,
I'll be down there four days.
World Champ.
What a great fucking story for 10 years.
That store I fucking love Brisbane.
And then beats Dan Henderson.
And a close decision for this book was a
fucking fight.
You forget about that fight when you
talk about fights of the year.
That fight was so good.
So good.
And again,
his cardio.
You got he,
he landed h bomb twice.
Landed it that Zombie Mod back and just
starts fucking box and it's fucking
crazy.
It's got nothing to tell you.
Something I had a funny feeling about
Luke rockhold.
Luke was taking it seriously I think
four days and I'm like,
he already beat bisping two fucking
years.
All it needs is one shot,
but business name and knockout artists
like the bedding off for him to knock
Luke rockhold on the first round.
I don't know.
Let me tell you something,
if my daughter catches you with one of
those swinging overhand punches and
clips,
the tip of your chin,
you got a problem.
Brian told,
he went to this new blocks in gym and
the guys that came mind,
if this girl is going to kill me for
telling the story,
you might have this girl jumps in there
and squat some rounds in.
Brian's like,
sure.
He starts walking around.
This bitch is dead serious and shit.
Some of the right hand.
Brian was like,
Oh shit.
He said,
he's like a little wobbled myself.
Anyone catches you flushed,
man,
you're going to be in for a long night.
I see the point of that.
The way rockhold cotton and bisbing
bisbing swung it over the shoulder,
was a beautiful left hook.
He stepped in with it and just whipped
it over the top and it was something
that him and Perillo had seen in rock
holds game coach of the year.
Very good code.
Hands down.
Coach of the Jesus coach.
He worked with Bj.
He's worked with a lot of guys.
Dj Tito,
Cris Cyborg,
and Michael Bisping.
He's a quiet guy in terms of what?
He's not out there trying to get a lot
of publicity.
He's not a attention whore is just an
excellent boxing coach.
Really knows his shit.
I'm one of the best in game and good at
adapting it for MMA too.
He understands MMA and it's like,
you know,
it's like there's those camps that do
it.
They don't want to hear something
fucking crazy that Woodley told me the
other day would love to.
I went to dinner with Woodley and mighty
mouse and some dude and his wife who won
the um,
uh,
they want some vip thing,
UFC thing and we met them dog route to
and I had dinner with them.
I'm with didn't have a fucking head
coach.
He coached himself up until the Calvin
gasoline fight.
The Calvin gasoline fight was the first
fight that he worked with Duke roufus
and he was trying to figure out if he's
going to go to att off.
He's got to work with Duke roufus that
att before his son.
No,
he never had like a head coach.
You go down there and do a camp.
Fuck,
was he thinking just talented,
talented and just figuring it out on his
own.
His son told him to go to Chicago or
Milwaukee rather held to such a little
kid.
Told him he had the idea that his dad
should.
You should go.
He goes,
I got it.
it was 15 below zero.
Got My fucking car and drove to
Milwaukee.
Then looked at him and he won.
He beat Calvin and then he's won every
fight since then.
This one,
the title this day and age,
you have to have that head coach.
You have to.
You have to have all bases covered.
Does another guy be distracted with
this?
You can't be doing this over here.
You can't live here.
Then flying just for your camp.
You can't decide to get serious six
weeks before that.
People are too good,
but how can you imagine that the NFL did
that?
Tom Brady was like,
I'm going to do this even though I'm in
season.
Then right before training camp starts,
so I'm gonna get serious.
They can't.
You just can't man.
Yeah,
and Duke's another guy that doesn't get
enough credit because he's another guy.
It's pretty quiet like Duke roufus is
not out there trying to make a lot of
noise and get a lot of people to pay
attention to him.
It's just an awesome striking coach.
Amazing strength coach.
I think the reason why maybe he doesn't
get enough credit with the Woodley's
because what's going on with pedals?
Yeah.
That's the only reason badasses in a
weird state.
How man?
I mean,
he can't fight at 1:45.
It's just too weak for him.
He just can't take it.
You know?
You watch that fight and it's like,
God,
Max Holloway just beat the fuck out of
him.
But like
I don't get why you went to 45 million
is lost at 55.
It's like it's not that bad.
You talking about split decision,
the decisions,
it's really not that bad.
You obviously can compete in the top
five there.
He definitely competed and could
actually go the full distance while
getting beat up.
Whereas at 45,
his body was breaking down and he even
said,
he goes,
I did everything in my power to make
weight.
I just my body shut down on it to tell
you guys maybe he should just go fucking
heavy.
Just start strength and conditioning
work.
Start fucking doing dead lifts and Shit.
Be beef his body up.
Because if you look at dos Anjos,
there's Dasan Joe's before.
I'm like Habib number got that off and
then there's also hundreds afterwards.
You mean?
You mean you saw it?
I don't know what you're saying.
You saw johnny who you are,
who you are,
but there is absolutely a difference
when a guy gets on a serious strength
and conditioning routine,
regardless of Mexican supplements.
He went with Nickerson.
Nickerson.
You ever seen the videos of Hockfield?
Dos?
Anjos and curse.
I'm working on doing work.
Curse on is a beast.
He has guys doing crazy shit.
He's got you doing all that.
Marvin Marinovich Shit.
Well you got all this footwork stuff and
he believes in like foot strength.
Above all,
all plyometrics,
all these explosive box jumps and shit
and all this crazy fucking burpees and
all the,
the nutty explosive sprinting back and
forth because for one,
I love that Meta chick for awhile.
Remember Carlos Condo is a climate on
trees and shit and fucking connor was
doing all this weird stuff and then all
of a sudden just the meat head movement
is back the meat head movement.
How so?
Like what was that?
That training is not a meathead.
I wouldn't say.
I'm not saying that meat head movement
at all.
I think that's the opposite.
No,
no,
no.
What I'm saying is that that raw power,
that strength condition,
you can't make up for that by climbing
on trees and doing this weird yoga
movement.
All that shit.
There's room for that.
That's all good.
But you got your focus,
your fucking focus.
But Connor,
what what?
What Connor's been able to do is develop
like extremely agile back and forth
movement and I think a lot of that is
that ido portal guy.
I got to admit that is weird.
As his stuff looks,
when he's flipping around and doing all
these jumps,
if you can move your body like that,
that's going to directly translate into
your footwork and your movement.
I'd give more credit to his head coach.
One hundred percent mean John,
Kevin Wisdom it.
Speaking of that use to.
You know who the biggest winner is?
Who?
Conor mcgregor.
How so he's the only star.
Oh yeah.
He's the only mega stone goes.
He gets all the stock.
You fell.
You fell as you want to talk.
Now what do you want to do?
Because I'm the only guy left.
Well,
how about this?
Hits that.
And then the next paper view is Holly
Holm versus a Germane to Rhonda May,
which is.
It's a tough sell.
I would buy it as a hardcore fan,
but for sure for sure.
And we'll probably,
but the bottom line,
100,
100,000
people.
Well yeah.
Yeah.
It ain't going to be Connor Mcgregor
numbers.
Right.
Bottom line comment when she lost,
and I'm sure he likes Rhonda by,
but business wise he's excellent.
Excellent.
Yeah,
that's.
Well,
it's a tricky situation now with the
marketing campaign,
the dumb yet wme wme put together for
this.
It was so Rhonda heavy and then Rhonda
gets smashed and now what are you going
to do for it?
You're gonna like the girl who smashed
Rhonda.
Is that what Amanda gets for her next
title?
You do a press tour.
World press door with her.
Like let's,
let's introduce you to the girl.
Beat the shutter.
Rhonda.
Now she's not fighting.
Let's do this press tour that she
deserved.
So they do all this stuff.
Piggyback on Ronda again.
Yes.
And show the beating.
Well,
you know,
she sort of retired two legends in the
sport.
That's why she's my fighter of the year.
She retired Nisha.
And then she retired.
Rhonda if Rhonda retires.
That's huge.
She retired.
Both of them.
All of a sudden,
Amanda is Nate Diaz,
did you say cat Zingano posted on
instagram that Amanda blocked her
because Cat Zingano,
uh,
stopped.
Amanda and Amanda was a hurting cats and
donald bad first round real bad.
I was in big fucking trouble,
but she survived and went on to stop.
Amanda and I love cat,
but I'll,
I'll,
uh,
fucking America dudes like you lost the
chick.
I just beaten 17 seconds,
but she got caught in an arm bar.
I mean,
how did Amanda lose the fight?
I don't remember if she beat her down.
She beat her down the third round.
Cat got on top and started blasting her
and she kinda gas.
No.
Well she kinda.
Gas is ferocious.
Amanda,
you know that fucking scream.
There's a is a recording of Cat Zingano
screaming after she won that fight.
And it's so primal.
Dude.
It's like an animal screen.
I think you played it before on the
podcast because it was,
it was like when she did it,
I was like,
Ooh,
there's some shit you hear.
That's cool.
Come on man.
That can't fake that.
That's in your bones.
That's your number.
That's after all that darkness.
She dealt with,
her husband committed suicide and just
all this diabetes was that.
That was after.
That is.
That was the virus afterwards was the
play that again,
Jamie plays out again.
Listen to this shit.
But to answer your question from before,
not to interrupt you,
this sitting on a goldmine,
William Morris now with this fuck Amanda
Nunez.
I told you last night she spotted the
lbgt community.
Jack fucking pockets.
Okay.
LBTG.
It's Lbgtq a.
Now listen,
what does that got to keep up lesbians?
I don't know how churches.
One lottery ticket.
They just hit the fucking lottery thing.
ASEXUALS are in there today.
Carmouche before
that.
But it still wasn't the champion work
once you're the chair.
She's the champion.
But it's everything.
And when Liz carmouche fought Ronda,
she fought her at the first fight when
no one knew who Ronda was.
So Rhonda has all this hype behind her.
She wins that fight and then goes on.
And you know Liz has done well in the
UFC,
but having that it does.
It's not the same.
Tony Evans says she has her.
Victor,
she's awesome.
Have you ever seen her fight?
Tony Evans.
Very tough.
She is bad ass.
She's an eviction.
Super tough.
She's really good.
And she's openly gay too.
And what way does she?
She's hilarious man.
I love that chick.
She's like 1:35,
1:35,
1:45.
She's good.
This is going to be more.
It says the same thing we were talking
about like when Anderson was in his
prime,
when he was just a light and people on
fire.
The division was like,
there wasn't,
you know,
you had to like Patrick [inaudible].
He had a couple of fights for the title
palace.
Latus real like there's no one frank,
there's no rich.
Franklin was the champ,
but there's no overwhelming need to see
that fight.
You know what I mean?
Like you want to see the fight because
I'm interested in.
See,
Patrick's got a great chin,
he's got power,
let's see what happens.
But it's not like,
oh,
here's the next one.
It's like cody garbrandt fighting
dominick Cruz.
We were like,
oh,
let's see what happened to us.
There was no one like that for Anderson
for a long ass time and I think in the
women's bantamweight division you got to
kind of similar situation.
Now it's like now you have Amanda Nunez,
who beats the shit out of Misha.
Misha is going to step back.
She's gone now.
She beats the shit out of a Rhonda.
Rhonda steps back.
Holly goes up to 1:45
remainder random.
Ain't got to change that shit.
Why fight for both belts to save that
card?
Fuck yeah.
I mean let's make some moves because.
Because if you've seen the car window,
the cop man holly's car.
How was the headliner?
That's what I'm saying.
Holly's fighting Germane to random may
for the 1:45
pounds.
I think they should give Jermaine
demand.
You may thousand dollars a has already
beat her,
but you know they need a new lesbian who
I thought Nunez Nunez already beat
Jermaine.
She beat her in the UFC.
Jermaine is a wicked kickboxer her.
She's a world world class multiple time
world champion kickboxer.
I think she's,
I think she won the Moitai world.
Moy Tai try titles several occasions.
She's like really elite as a Meu Thai.
But they'd gloves stand up,
stand up.
There's no ground.
And as soon as she got in the UFC you
could see like that transition between
learning,
the striking with uh,
with,
with take downs versus just fighting
kickboxing about.
It's a big transition.
Takes time,
but you're also going to people who
aren't going to give you the time.
Exactly.
They just fucking shooting out on her
and beating her up and taking her down
and just.
It's just a different sport.
I thought the card is pretty good.
It's in Brooklyn.
Yes.
Travis Browne is fight.
Derrick Lewis.
That's an interesting fight.
But what's.
You know
what is true?
Where's Travis has head out right now?
He's training the same camp,
isn't he?
Yes.
God dammit.
Travis.
Yeah.
Holly Holm versus Amanda Nunez.
That's the fight right there.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
I think at 1:35
lights will do that at this.
For this card.
No.
Make It.
Make Amanda the two belt champion.
But then you have to remember the
volunteership Shevchenko just beat holly
and Peter's come up 10 losses.
Yeah.
And Valentino beat her up.
Stand up together.
Yeah.
They need help with this car.
The problem is most people,
you know,
volunteer one,
they don't know who she is yet,
even though she won.
I mean she needs a few more victories
inside the UFC in order to get people
excited about this paper.
Yeah,
Brooklyn.
The only reason people know holly too is
they don't know the.
Her past losses really?
They granted her fight was on Fox,
but all they know is she's the girl that
knocked out Rhonda.
That's what's selling this.
Eddie Bravo.
You trying to say that this isn't going
to get your last 60 bucks.
I'm just saying that I will illegally
streamed the last one.
Amanda Nunez just Vod for 45 seconds.
She's fresh.
Have her headline.
That car.
Hey Man,
let's build her up.
What's the.
Where's the.
Where's the superbowl card?
Can't I know.
I agree with that.
That's not.
That's February.
Nothing.
No,
no.
Super Bowl weekend is in Houston.
Different Card.
Oh,
it is?
Yeah,
he's totally changed in one.
I don't think they have that card locked
up either,
by the way.
I think there's still moving fights
around for that Brooklyn Card because I
think they recognize that they did need
a little bit more juice on that card in
Vegas this year.
It's in Houston this year and the suit
bulge and he she or is it a problem?
Houston or Dallas?
I thought it was.
Downs is a Houston,
Texas,
so that's a,
they'll have a big card for,
uh,
for the UFC there.
They don't have a great.
Now is Bermudez and chance on John.
That's a good fight.
But what,
what a day is that?
That would sell seven paper.
February,
fifth,
fourth,
fifth.
The fourth.
Yeah.
So one of those cards.
I'm not there for that.
You need to slow down.
Jesus Christ.
That's the fight.
That's a superbowl card and it's a fight
night.
What's the soup bowl?
We superbowl week.
That's it.
The 29th.
The game is on the fifth.
That's the night before.
It's a free flight.
Free fight night because superbowl
weekend,
it's always been a paper view.
UFC.
It's usually been in vegas.
Vegas,
yeah.
I wonder whether the only man.
Well,
you know what man is going to headline
cards right now to sell the paper,
but it's a good fucking question.
There's no heavy weights other than
steep Emile Church that can sell a big
card right now and he has to sell it in
Cleveland too.
There's a lot of stars out there.
There's a lot of stars out that would
sell us.
Guy Who?
Eddie.
Which one?
Serious and and just give me three.
Ankle.
Well,
Alpha Centauri has really didn't.
I mean she put in 45 seconds.
Take.
There's.
I mean,
do you want.
I'm talking about legit paper view
sellers.
The honestly there's conor mcgregor in
this.
Everybody else.
There was a thing that they showed the
other day that connor in three fights
drew more paper view than the entire UFC
roster in 2014.
His is three worst gates and paper is
all time.
We beat Ronda is best and brock Lesnar's
best.
He's the best.
He's the biggest for sure and no,
no,
but some people are looking at you and
Dana's our hate it.
Right.
You know what Ron is?
His is like,
here's what's different.
When Rhonda,
his face came on the screen the first
time in Vegas this weekend,
I heard young girl scream and that's all
I heard.
I heard young girls.
It was like Justin Bieber pulled his
dick out.
How about,
how about talking shit about beavers
talking shit.
No,
he made a tweet that said you just got
knocked the fuck out.
Hey bieber singing fucking songs.
No music with the fuck you're talking
about that dude.
So sick.
I can't stand when people aren't
involved in the game.
They say stuff like that.
It's like,
what have you ever done to risk your
what?
What are you talking about?
Yeah.
Damn it got it's 39,000
likes and it's because Rhonda,
her shoes at some concert or something
into her little sister on meet Biba and
he didn't have time.
So then she got mad,
remember that?
She was like,
fuck.
So that's where it stems from,
like waiting,
like,
well you remember when,
when fucking Rhonda got killed by Holly
Trump said,
uh,
I'm glad she got knocked out.
Not a good person to talk shit again.
Denise trumped did another tweet about
Rhonda,
about Rhonda and he's the president of
the United States.
I'm pretty sure he is so critical to his
tweet.
He's so,
why was he mad at Rhonda on the first
fucking know she could talk shit about
him.
She said she goes,
I would,
I would never vote for trump.
Yeah.
She said she was going to vote for
Bernie in the United States.
Motherfucker.
What do you care?
No.
Hey Man,
don't you have bigger fires to put out
instead of tweeting bullshit.
Not only that politician.
Matt,
that's not what he is.
He's not,
he's not.
He don't even want to stay at the
lighthouse because I gotta I gotta get
the Fuck Outta Shit.
It's probably rubbed down to the playboy
mansion.
It's nasty.
Milgard windows.
Shit.
You been in the mansion right?
Didn't you come with me.
And then the marijuana policy project at
first when I first got invited to the,
uh,
the mansion,
I thought,
oh my God,
it's going to be just like those videos
you see,
they used to be the like commercials and
Little Jon voight mansion and you'd see
like on EU,
she's the playboy mansion and you're
like,
Oh shit,
we get invited to an event there.
And then you figured you figured it out
really quick.
That okay.
Not every night goes off because there's
like no girls there.
They had giant screens everywhere in the
backyard,
plain loops of people partying on the
good nights.
So you got this,
you're at the party at the playboy and I
looked into it and it turns out they
rent out the place like all the goddamn
going to be.
It's not like what you see on TV.
There's only two times per year where
it's that what you imagined where
they're just 80 percent girls and
they're all in there.
That does happen,
but it's only the Halloween party and
their fourth of July or a midnight
summer's eve possible to get into that.
Do you remember when we'd see fights?
There was fights.
The strikeforce bottleneck to attach.
Man,
that was a tough loss and it's probably
over in it.
Yeah.
He just.
He looked terrible on the ground,
man.
He was making big rookie mistakes and
super amateur.
Yeah.
We just like he was.
He was like leaving himself open.
It wasn't patient.
It's hard to Tony,
if you saw them in the gym,
you're like,
go home.
Like I've seen me as the best in the
world.
Like this motherfucker's going to do it,
man.
So what is it a commitment to the
grappling commitment to grappling
commitment to a Jujitsu?
Yeah,
me just so good at standup.
He,
you know,
his dad's this legend in Denver as far
as striking and he was a taekwondo guy
and he trained him since he was little
and Thatcher was always the it factor in
the gym where you're like,
dude,
if you're staying with him,
good luck.
He could do it all both ways.
Whatever you wanted.
He can mimic anything.
He looked good standing up to man.
It was amazing.
But he made the mistake of,
of initiating the grappling.
I was like,
Jesus Christ and what hurts him even
more.
I don't know if you guys saw this with
all the chaos going on with UFC two.
Oh seven.
Their head coach,
leaster Bolin who was my head coach,
right?
And I think one of the best in the game
is retiring.
He's leaving a Mussel farm.
Why is he doing that?
Because his kids,
his kids in wrestling and he lives far
away and he's like,
don't spend too much time with the guys
traveling stuff.
That was in the summer.
I had three weekends with my kids.
He's like,
I just can't do it.
And his,
his,
his son,
little easters like really getting
competitive and wrestling and leasers
his wrestling coach.
How far away does he live from the gym?
Why can our.
That sucks.
You should move closer to fuck.
But again,
he's like,
because he owns his own business.
He makes crazy money so he's just doing
it and it Kinda got out of hand.
He's like,
do.
I'm spending too much time with the
team.
None of time with my family.
He's a good dude too.
One of the best.
Really good guy.
Very smart too.
I tell you what I'd like to see and I
have no idea.
I don't know if they've talked about so
I'm going to do it,
but I'd like to see Matt Brown take kind
of a leadership role with that team
really and move that into the next phase
of his career.
I don't even know if he's into it.
I've seen him with the guys and with his
mentality and experience.
You're talking about a coach kind of
knows it all.
Like we were talking about with Matt
Hume,
who's been there be a good idea.
I have no idea if he's even into it.
Yeah,
it was interesting because Dwayne was
working with Matt Brown for this fight.
He work with them for a few weeks,
but I thought maybe
we'd see more like footwork and movement
from Matt that's like similar to Dwayne
style,
but dwayne style doesn't work that way.
Duane,
you have to be in and you have to spend
a ton of time with them and I really
think he's the perfect coach for Tj,
but unless you're one of those small
guys with that crazy footwork,
he's not a guy who can go to for six
weeks and pick shit up.
Oh,
you know what man,
I agree with you,
but do you remember when Travis Browne
was first on the scene?
Like when he fought a skyscraper?
Any funny mood like Dominick Cruz at
alliance.
That's what I'm saying.
The entire division was like,
what the fuck are we going to do?
Yeah.
Well what happened to him?
Edmond?
100 percent,
100 percent.
Think about all those fights since he
left there.
He was a bar man.
I always said that he was the dark horse
in the division.
I was like,
let me tell you something that this guy
puts it all together.
He can do some shit that you rarely see
from a heavyweight.
Went from alliance to Winkeljohn for
awhile.
Yes.
Always.
He,
he went,
he went to a alliance,
then he went to Jackson's and was good
there.
Those guys.
Then overeem,
stayed there.
Then he left and then he ended up going
to a Edmond with Rhonda.
So,
but I,
I.
same thing I met on,
I forget what UFC it was ufc one,
I forget.
Anyways,
um,
I fought Ben Rothwell.
He was on the card fighting some scrub
and I looked at my coach and I was like,
do you get,
do you know about that guy?
And it was leased fingers a little bit.
I went,
he's probably your next heavy weight
champ.
Have you seen the way moves on?
We don't want to fight them like down
the road.
Want to fight them soon because I got so
much talent.
He's probably the next champ.
They're like,
really?
Then we saw him and was like,
Jesus Christ.
I'm like,
he has footwork like dominick Cruz and
he's a c,
six seven.
Yeah.
You know,
I talked to Brian,
stand about him and Brian was pretty
adamant about it,
like after the last fight,
he's like,
where's all this footwork worlds?
He's like,
I remember this guy having an incredible
footwork and movement when he was at
Jackson's camp and now he's just kind of
lost all of it and he's become this
stagnant,
like great.
Has the same desire anymore.
Like when he knocked out Gonzaga or Josh
Brown.
Bingo.
You know Josh,
Josh Barnett,
brother who just got flagged.
Yeah,
he got flagged.
Huh?
What do you know what for steroids?
Really?
Hey Man,
that guy,
he's been flagged before for God's love.
Josh Shit happens.
He's got caught a few times.
A whole Edmund somebody put a video out
pretty funny about everybody getting
knocked out admin camp with a little
flute like fucking type panic and shit,
you know?
And it's uh,
it's,
it's fucking sad.
You know,
right before the Fight I had to pee.
I was paying,
I said to myself,
you know what,
I can't call this fight,
but what do I want to happen?
Let just pull girl fucking win.
Let him let her retire with Amanda.
She would never retired if she won,
you know,
whatever.
I was hoping I didn't want to see what I
just saw again.
Yeah,
but why do we feel that way that I see,
but you didn't see what you just saw
again,
what you saw was
way worse with holly fight.
It was her trying to get holly,
but holly was fighting wisely.
She was sliding away.
Cracking noise shots.
It was Rhonda Being Ron.
She got hunted.
Yes.
Rhonda got hunted down and destroyed by
an assassin on totally different kind of
profile on tim down right now.
If I get up and go and say I have two
seconds before his head adjust and he
realized his way.
He is.
Even that if I got on top of them,
insight control was big as fat as I am
and you'll go,
fuck,
I can't breathe,
but you know,
but after a while you get it together.
She didn't even get it together,
but it's all to do.
The big difference is getting hit in the
head.
Oh,
when you get a headship,
probably had no idea what the fuck was
going on,
but it was like.
But Joe,
she just came from a training camp.
Was her media scrum stuff like training
camp?
Usually she's got little guys.
She's thrown around in training camp.
This time I didn't see her throwing
nobody around the trinet.
She's definitely had judo work.
She's definitely doing a lot of work.
Was She?
There was some footage that was up
sheet.
Hidden takedowns towel.
A admin.
I don't want to see nobody.
I don't want to talk to.
Nobody was a training reflective of her
attitude towards the media and
everything like this.
Yeah.
There's something that's not fucking
right here.
Joe.
I love you.
I appreciate the headshot,
but something wasn't there.
I get shot in the head.
I put my hand.
Fair to say was not there because
something was not there that that's why
I feel under public.
I mean guys were brilliant.
You feel broken heart in a way.
It's weird.
Why would we feel broken than I do to
hold you up the next morning and told
you you were driving back from the
airport?
Like,
I'm broken me.
Everybody gets fired after Holly Holm.
Everybody.
I go back to the Japanese cultural
center when Misaki Donna for $7 every
time.
That's not what made Rhonda.
Rhonda.
She's so loyal but something.
But if she was so loyal,
she wouldn't let the guy that got her
into the UFC guy who website,
not the manager managers.
Different managers come back.
She wouldn't have left 10.
She knows what that deal is different.
That's different though,
right?
This,
but there's two different versions of
that story who I don't know who's right
and I feel the same way where for
whatever reason,
right?
Yes,
I agree 100 percent sure.
The head punches great,
but something wasn't there.
Joe Wasn't there when she went to
Grandpa Joe.
Joe Breland like this was Rhonda that
came out for Holly and chill.
You remember that time when he told me a
Mug,
that gay guy and he beat the shit out of
you.
Get in trouble.
Now let's.
That's what happened was God highs that
were thinking they wanted to be gay guys
that had families and shit that wanting
to get the dick suck would have a few
drinks in them and they'd go to Hudson
county park to see if there was somebody
there to get the Dixon before I wanted
to show shell parked.
Shaundra said parking lot.
I didn't park in that lot.
I parked in the lot that was empty and
when I was walking over there,
some dude kept making eye contact with
me.
He wanted me to suck Dick.
He,
you know,
when somebody looks at it,
know when somebody looks at me because
they see me from the podcast getting his
head.
No,
no,
no.
I know exactly.
I know it's either he had either.
He wanted to sell me drugs.
Oh,
he wanted to suck my dick.
Okay.
How'd you decide that it was dick?
How creepy.
It was.
Just his appearance.
I don't want to say he look gay,
but just as a pretty little guy.
He was a male.
Prostitute.
Mouth is watering.
Okay.
So anyway,
so these guys,
these guys will come down and they'd be
half drunk.
Like in hindsight I think about it and
they all these types of dudes that may
not just be gay,
they just have a family,
but they liked the scene in 1980 you.
It wasn't easy to go.
I'm coming out of the closet.
There was a lot of guys and let me talk
to you about stuff.
Been around.
The Guy told me the truth as a man
around the guy that when you get in your
car and go home,
you're like,
you know one for sure.
I could definitely talk that in the
second question.
He's dying or something like,
even though he's got a hot girlfriend
and they got a dog and he goes to
fucking crossfit.
You can tell.
Maybe he could talk them into switching
governments if he's got a lot of dudes
like that.
When a kid is walking his dog,
it's like,
fuck,
am I gay?
No,
no,
no.
Evil fantasies like robin fantasy.
But he was gay as fuck.
No,
that's not saying that,
but I'm just saying that you got another
thing.
There's a lot of fucking guy's dog that
you see that you know,
maybe their dad's still alive and he was
a marine.
You can't,
you can't go home and tell your dad was
a general guys.
If your dad was alive and you want to
blow guys Rogan,
urine in color,
how many guys do you think are out there
right now?
We've had this,
this millions that have married
whatever,
but every once in a while they put a
feather suit on and they'd go dance like
in anything.
It's probably more than 10.
And that's what we used to.
We used to go down and we was dumb kids.
We figured out we can rob these dudes
that were drunk.
They'd come down and get the Dick
sucked.
So we got the captain,
the police's son,
so we weren't going to go to jail.
He was better looking than you were
going to go to.
We put him out there.
We could put like a a Guinea tee shirt,
you know those white beans with little
gold chain with a cocktail.
We put them out there and then we hide
in the trees and then he'd go and suck
his Dick and the guy would park and then
he'd walk them back and right before I
went through to get that one knee,
I come up with that straight,
right,
kicked Jon Jones to the fucking nut
sack.
Go down.
We were in the trees in the trades.
Fuck.
Fucking fly down from the tree and we
detain Pam.
Pam,
we take your money and we run with 16
guys.
You don't.
Nobody knows what's right and what's not
that my mother,
no.
Perfect guy.
The host who is.
You got to remember my crew was the
third crew out there was a crew from
64th street.
They will not only robbing you,
they were taking you to your house.
I had friends that were in high school
that actually would get.
Was setting you up here.
Let's get thick and then they put you
back in your car and go to your house
and rob you.
We were the light crew.
We were just going down.
They're peppering you with a few shots.
I'm running away with again,
my point,
but the store was,
there was one time where he got beat up.
I went down there by myself.
You went to.
Yeah,
you went by myself.
I had to mix minus the eight and a half
and I only won by eight,
so by the and I called my buddy that I
go dog,
we lost and he goes,
I'm with my girlfriend,
but at the time I'm with you on it up.
I'm hanging out with my buddies back,
do nothing to me.
He lit me up.
It was.
It could have been known as his uncle,
his uncle.
He punched me with so many shots,
but again,
he lit up,
lit me.
I'd had a bronco.
But here's the funny thing that in
hindsight now I know what Joe's saying.
Levels of striking.
I never saw striking.
It was nighttime,
so I didn't even see his hands.
I just kept seeing it.
Kept seeing the light.
When you see lights at night,
that's the motherfucker had some
training.
It's funny.
There's a funny thing about striking
too,
and this relates to what Amanda can do.
There's power and then there's like,
whoa,
power.
There's like crazy God gifted
boundaries.
Some people just have it and you see it
with Linacre.
Linacre for sure.
Has it rumbled for sure.
Has It?
There's people that have this weird
power,
they have an ability to hit people and
you see people that normally can take a
shot and you see the look in their eye
when they're in big trouble,
like right away.
And when you get hit like that,
man,
you don't know where the fuck you are.
Let me ask you this.
In Jujitsu,
uh,
every black belt knows how to do a rear
naked choke,
but very few people can do a rear naked
choke like Marcella Garcia.
Very few people.
Uh,
it's because.
Would you,
would you say it was natural,
like Linacre or
was it because he spent a lot of time
perfecting the back?
And I know for a fact that he did,
he used to,
he used to ride on people's backs with
the over under and not even trying to
tap him.
He would just spend a lot of time just
riding and perfecting the control.
Then he just mastered the fight and then
he,
he realized how important that squeeze
was so that he would ride and squeeze
and he knew that it was all about the
power of the squeeze.
So he's spent a lot of time with the
rear naked choke and you know,
there's a lot,
there's,
there's quite a few guys out there now
that,
that are,
uh,
have a foul,
you know,
his students and other guys that have
developed back attacks is,
is,
is almost as good as marcel,
but probably not as good now when you're
talking about power,
you know,
the certain guys have the power whether
they're born with it or not.
What if just what if the guys with the
power actually in their training working
harder and more consistently at
developing power.
Like what would you need?
Like you got that is a possibility,
but it's also a physics issue.
It's also an anatomy.
It's both though.
It might be both,
but there's the big right.
It is like,
okay,
here's the Kurt Cody Garbrandt is not a
big hands.
He's not built like a George Foreman
type character.
Like George Foreman has freakish
physical attributes,
he's got hands and they're like the size
of like canned hams there,
fucking gigantic and he would just slump
just some guys with a jab and you'd see
them get stunned and hurt.
Obviously trained like a motherfucker
obviously had very good check technique
to obviously worked on all those things
too,
but you can't overcome the physical
attributes if a guy does all those other
things as well,
that's where the freaks come in.
That's where the people that just have
this ridiculous one shot power.
There's just an.
But there's technique.
We can look at Congress on a big guy.
He's a wide shoulder guy,
but he has that one hitter quitter.
Yeah,
no question,
but when you think about your turning
sidekick,
right?
Like your personal turning sidekick,
it's everybody knows now that it's
extremely powerful,
a scary,
powerful,
very few people.
I've never seen anybody throw turned
inside.
Kick as hard as you have.
I've worked with a lot of martial
artists in my time.
Still to this day.
Holy Shit Up.
Michael White.
Excuse me.
He's right up there too,
but he's like six,
four to 40 anyways.
Uh,
but you have said many times that the,
the,
the secret behind your power was the
reps.
you knew that it was all about just
hitting that heavy bag as many goddamn
times as possible every day to standing
in front.
And you said that most people don't
develop that power because most people
just don't spend the time stealing a bag
and just working.
So that was also built though.
Well,
that to listen,
man.
There was a lot of guys that I trained
with and had good turning sidekicks.
I always knew that I had a cheat.
I had a physical advantage,
like the
size of my hands for someone my size.
I mean you have to realize I had hands
as big when I was fighting at 1:54.
It was ridiculous.
They were just there.
Just certain physical attributes to the
width of the shoulders is big,
but that has nothing to do with your
turn inside dies.
It does because in the hips to ask all
the explosive.
It's also the fast fiber with powers.
A lot of it is fast twitch and you
didn't have fast,
which you don't mean like Nick Diaz is a
hard puncher,
but he's never going to be a puncher
like weirdly,
but no matter what he does,
when he trains with it will never be
able to punch them.
In average,
your average a MMA fighter,
how much time do you think they spend
working on the power of their turning
sidekick?
Very guy,
very.
No one really fills a space side kick
very well.
There's a few guys allotted a certain
amount of time a week for 20 minutes I'm
going to power how many guys,
folks on throwing a right hand or left
hand?
If they're dominant.
Lefthanded are southpaws does.
There's only.
There's very few can do it in one punch
and knock guys out.
You know,
fighters that specifically train
everyday just to develop specific
punching.
Like today I'm going to expense power
punches right in between camps in
between shows do that for sure.
Guys will just like go.
Like George was famous for doing that.
He would go down to [inaudible] and just
just only trained Jujitsu for like
months on end,
you know,
just to really tighten everything up.
You went to Brazil a couple of times
just to train in boxing.
You know,
I would do a dachsund towards what's the
best thing you can do?
Like you're a professional fighter.
You fight in the UFC,
you ranked 13th and you want to take
your,
your power of your hand.
You want to be able to knock someone.
You want to be.
You want to have that conor mcgregor
strength.
What do I gotta do to get weight out?
I don't think so.
Genetics.
Genetics has a lot to do with it.
Ninety percent of if you go see
somebody,
they could clean up the efficiency.
Yes.
It's your shoulders.
Technique is a lot of stuff that goes
into that punch.
You know,
if a wrestler,
a world champion wrestler came in and I
came in and I was world champion
wrestler,
but my punches weren't that hard.
I think in time.
True.
But let me tell you something.
You talk to someone who's a real boxing
trainer and they will tell you that
there are guys that just come in and for
whatever reason they might not have ever
boxed before,
but you have them throw a jab and
they're like,
and you're like,
oh Jesus,
whatever.
For sure there's those pen.
Then it makes it better.
You know the technique,
like if you look at a guy like Sergei
Kovalev who's a vicious knockout
artists,
vicious puncher,
he's got both.
He's got the the,
the beautiful technique,
but he also has that free gift.
God given strength.
Those are the guys that oftentimes wind
up being champions to.
To that point,
look at Andre Ward who just fought,
who doesn't hide trains more than
surrogate.
He was an Olympic medalist.
Gold medalist has been training,
fighting since he was 10.
I think so,
yeah.
He works on power punches,
but he's not a knockout or saying you're
a head coach of a team.
You until all your fighters to a era
that bar north power.
You're not.
Don't worry about working on your power.
Just work or not.
I always work on your power editor.
You can always improve everything,
but you're never going to get it to that
rumble level like I'm never going to
tell them,
hey,
let's let's pick our shots here.
Let's do more volume.
Can you do specifically 15 minutes a
week,
30 minutes a week it.
We're focusing on developing power.
You're not known for a rugby coach,
doesn't matter.
Two years.
We're going to do.
What is it though specifically with
dumbbells like Muhammad and just throw
punches.
I
certainly do some strength and
conditioning work that would help.
Just setting a back,
hitting a bag would help a lot.
Hitting power shop.
Maybe it's all the above.
Will help.
Like evander holyfield started working
out with Mackie.
She'll stone when he went up from
cruiserweight to heavyweight,
so we did a lot of weight lifting and
his power came along with weight on
them.
Put a lot of weight on and maybe Mexican
supplements,
so explosive and maybe definitely
Mexican supplements.
One hundred percent,
100 percent,
and he could win the Olympia at the same
time,
but the guys who are like,
like there's a good video of Joseph
Volta on is go to have a bazooka.
Joe Valtellina on his instagram page
fault Illini who was glory champion,
how to step back for it because because
of concussions and I think he's gonna
stay retired,
but he hasn't decided yet,
but he went down on top.
I mean he's one of the best kickbox in
the world,
but there's a video of him hitting the
pads and just digging,
digging into pads and talking about like
the importance of sometimes just going
all out with power.
Just all our power shots on the paths.
Like watch.
I could see this guy.
He's a butt and when he's doing it,
when he's,
when he's hitting these pads,
the good thing about it is hands never
dropped from his chin.
Always good position,
but to really dig in and work only
solely on your power,
you don't want to do that all the time.
Like,
this is just something that you're going
to do occasionally and only,
you know,
every athlete has to decide.
It really depends on the person.
Depends on what else you're working on,
five minutes a day.
It's a bit like this combination.
This is so simple.
Combinations like right hand,
left hook,
right kick to develop,
right?
Isn't it better on a heavy bag then as
opposed to these?
Not necessarily.
That's just as good.
That's just as good that style,
but that's not as good for straight
kicks because you can't kick a person to
the body that way.
Like if I put a body pat on a dude and I
spinning back,
kick him,
he's going to get really hurt.
Like I'll break your ribs even with one
of those big body shields on it.
If you let someone spinning back kick
you in the body,
it's going to break your ribs.
There's some punches too.
If they.
If they do a liver shot on the coach
with a Ipad,
they'll drop the.
Drop them internal bleeding or hit soil.
Fuck up Mitch.
Yeah,
the dude who lost,
who was the first boxer that got choked
out in
the UFC?
I heard that dude.
Oh,
he can fuck some meds.
people snow piece.
He said,
Oh,
you got to put extra.
He will.
Fuck your shit up.
He was an artist when he was at his
best.
He was an artist.
He jumped from that national team that
let's say,
who's the best boxer most talented of
all time.
Every single person unanimously says,
James,
Tony,
even floyd mayweather,
the best we've ever seen.
Talent wise.
James Tony.
He was a bad motherfucker,
but he liked to eat.
He loved him.
Some fucking big banks.
That's a problem.
He got sick.
He went all the way up to heavyweight.
Remember that?
You know I'm James.
Tony started out his career at one 61 68
freak.
Super Freak to to to.
To that point though,
and we can end on that.
I'll get rid of it.
Look at baseball,
like Mark Mcguire.
He's never going to be a single base
guy.
He's a fucking guy who'd example full of
Mexicans supplements when he's at his
best.
True.
If you get that guy on the couch and had
them hit a baseball,
I mean how,
how much,
how much distance is the difference
between.
He might hit 30 home runs at a 70,
but still,
I mean he was in his genetics.
Big Forums,
powerful hips follow through.
He's never going to be the guy who would
bunt the ball or lead on so,
so same thing,
same thing,
Jack to the deals,
but that might not necessarily translate
into punching power,
which is really interesting.
It's like they might just be really good
at that.
You know,
punching power is a weird one,
man.
It's,
it's a real weird powers.
Just as quick as it hit hard because
that motherfucker throw hard.
It again that,
that movement from the hips,
all that same movement.
They said that when you.
They had a documentary on him that he
needs three draft 30 for 30 hells yeah.
They fucking slammed him while they had
a scam him up.
Like they had pulled a starting.
Brenda had a.
had a drafted because he didn't want to
go to Baltimore.
Yeah.
He don't want to go into the culture.
Man.
This shit kinky shit,
but bro,
this dude standing on the warning sign,
that's a true story.
He could stay at the hunt,
the warning track,
John Elway take one step and put the
ball right there and your glove at home,
but really that's deadly there.
There's a really.
You have no idea.
How far is that?
I have to say three.
Oh,
five,
305 feet.
Three hundred.
Five feet and he's easy throwing.
Is it?
Does it going up in the air or is it a
straight line?
Just a bullet bullet.
They're not to throw so fast for that
ball,
not to dry.
You have to watch some of the third
piece of fruit or like that.
It's very interesting how he didn't want
to play with Baltimore,
so somebody went to Stein brothers
office and they said,
we'd like for you to draft John Elway.
Steinbrenner goes and he opened up the
schedule for the fucking the line up for
like three years later.
He had always starting right field.
Here's why that's crazy.
His wife being able to throw from the
warning track into home plate,
as is crazy.
If you took a baseball and you through
it and you shot a bullet,
they would both drop at the same rate,
so the bullet is only going to be in
the air for a few seconds.
That's why you could be 200 yards away,
put your crosshairs on.
Someone pulled the trigger and then
boom,
they die immediately is because the
bullets traveling so fast,
but the drop has the same amount of
time.
So it depends on how long it takes to
get there.
It's how far it's going to drop.
So like if you're shooting someone
something from really far away,
like there's a lot of people that get
into long range shooting.
Like the goal in those ranges that will
hit these plates,
these steel plates that are like five,
800,000
yards away and you hear bang clink like
you.
There's a delay,
a noticeable delay,
and in that delay they have to calculate
the drop.
So like if they're shooting at that
plate there radical where they aim,
it has to adjust for the fact that this
bullet is going to drop and the amount
of time that it takes to get 800 yards
to aim higher.
Yeah,
so it's going to take a second or so or
half a second,
whatever it is.
So they have to aim higher so that its
scope adjust for that.
If you're throwing a baseball,
imagine how much slower than it is than
a bullet.
So you have to throw so fucking fast.
If you're throwing straight,
if you're just gonna,
throw straight,
silly and go get into home plate.
That mother fucker must be throwing a
bullet.
It must be crazy.
You know his receivers in Denver the
first few years I couldn't catch them of
catch the ball they played catch with
their pads and will be so hard.
Dude leave imprints on the nuclear
plants on the chance.
People crazy.
And that's a known,
that's a known skill that some people
just never developed the ability to
throw a fastball.
That's another one.
It's like punching paint discussed it
last time.
The dynamics of it,
I'll tell you who I think would
translate from if he threw a punch,
a guy who was explosive with as fuck and
could throw and do it all.
Bo Jackson.
Oh yeah.
Bo Jackson Bunch.
Have you taught both?
Jackson had a punch,
but you know,
here's another example.
Herschel Walker.
Herschel Walker could punch like a
motherfucker and he was a karate black
belt.
I mean he,
he fought a bunch of MMA fights deep
into his forties.
Remember Jack didn't like 48.
Bridgette giant six pack.
Not an ounce of fat.
Looks like a superhero like you'll
reveal,
but age to look old.
It was weird.
It didn't.
Real weird.
He still looks good.
He's in his fifties now.
Talking about having one more fight
before he stopped.
Yeah,
let's not.
But yeah.
Hearing why not get some.
How about fucking rising?
My gabby.
Go see grandma's going to post it.
I was going to pose it.
I got the video.
I was gonna.
I was just going to post what the fuck?
Japan.
Then I thought about it.
I go,
I can't do it.
It was running.
The chick was that.
Can we see that?
Yeah.
Do you know where it is?
Jamie?
I've got to pull it up here real quick.
Go ahead and put myself.
I'm going to put it up on instagram,
Jamie,
and when I put it up on instagram you
could.
I'm just going to put it up.
Have you seen this?
And I'm going to write a fucking huge
straight up grandma.
She comes out and is doing like the wwe
off the ropes.
Selfish.
Coming out like it's a game.
You don't mind girl.
Jessica?
Tap fucking Gabby Garcia.
Jessica who flowers.
Oh really?
She did in competition and competition
at worlds.
I just posted it.
So if you go to my instagram Joe Rogan,
you'll see it.
Just says what the fuck?
Japan WTF Japan and you see this one
woman,
our ring Jack to that tits.
Looks like Jose Conseco.
Nineteen 84.
Oh my God.
That old lady.
Which a thought of 50 year old woman who
looked like she hasn't worked out in a
year and she looks so scared.
Can we get a go fund me so she doesn't
have to do this shit?
That woman looks so scared to open.
Scared.
Can we re?
Can you refresh that God looks she needs
are in the body.
All my God and punches her in the face
and mercifully Gabby Garcia is not the
most vicious striker in the world.
Not The friendly is.
Oh,
it's hot.
Well,
she had to do what she had to do.
Would you take that fight,
Gabby?
Easy cash.
Well,
that must've been to north Hollywood and
give him massages are going to north
Hollywood and stuff.
I don't even think they give her the
option.
I think they just delay the trip to
North Hollywood.
Watch this.
Look how scared she is.
Look at our big deep breaths while she's
looking at Gabby's body.
She's like six,
four.
She's legit.
Six [inaudible] four,
probably two.
Oh,
totally natural.
And this grandma steroids are natural.
They all come from.
What the fuck is going on in Japan?
So crazy.
Are you doing so crazy?
Why that grandma?
Even in the.
I just can't.
Man.
I'm going to win.
No fans.
If I do this well,
I don't think most people have seen
this.
I just get the sucker Robin.
Nice knee braces on and place.
Yeah.
What is the reason why she did it?
This lady,
you gotTa.
Look how scared she shook her hand after
it's over and maybe she was a pro
wrestler or something.
Think she was a protester.
They probably gave her a big ass pay day
to lose a few years of her life.
What the fuck?
What the fuck and deed?
That's what the deal.
I will say this.
That's the worst Japanese freak show
I've ever seen because that was a woman
who did not belong.
That's the worst flight I've ever seen.
Yeah.
That's the worst.
The worst person ever.
The most brutal mismatch ever.
Yeah.
Horrible man.
Horrible.
Why?
But Kathy black belt.
Why didn't you just grab a hold of her
and choke her?
I mean she could have easily not even
hurt the old lady.
People will pay to watch anything on new
users.
I know,
but I mean if you're Gabby,
Gabby,
and you're looking at that old guy that
wants to fuck his dog,
you look them over five years.
Eve is eve.
Make it the way I got to go to the
solid.
See one of those videos when you were a
kid,
did you know anybody that had like a vhs
of like a barnyard?
You never saw the flux barnyard.
Oh No.
My friend billy when,
when I was 20,
I guess got a vhs tape of this chick
that got fucked by animals and we went
to his basement.
He had,
he had to hide it so he had to like go
get it.
And then we had a meet down the base and
then one of us had to watch the door so
that no one would,
uh,
you know,
one of the parents,
like.
So one of us was like on the stairs
looking down like railings in the
basement,
there's like the fucking gap between the
stairs and the railing.
So I don't remember who it was,
but he was like on the stairs,
like watching the TV through the gap
because he had to be the guy with his
arm up in case the door open because
we're watching this chick blow a fucking
dog and blow a horse and get fucked by a
donkey and all this different crazy
shit.
Same lady or multiple.
It was so grainy and so hard to tell,
but it was real.
I mean she really was like letting a dog
fucker.
She was like letting a pig fucker.
It was,
it was horrible.
It was horrible.
I,
I remember faces of death.
I remember being.
I couldn't even finish it.
I was so scared.
Do you understand?
I see them all.
You've seen them all.
Remember the woman they tied to?
Dude,
between two co,
two trucks pulled them apart.
I don't remember that.
Yeah,
it was in the Middle East.
Yeah.
I didn't get down or tired.
You got that x rayed and she took it all
under the one with the guy that the
newscaster that was walking backwards to
the alligator.
Got Him.
What?
He was like,
well,
here at the fucking clear clearwater,
Florida,
see the railing of the dumps and deeper
and deeper,
yes.
Now the children are going to stop it if
somebody comes and throws a blanket like
a leg pops up.
Oh my God,
the guy hang gliding and he had like the
camera and he's hang gliding.
Just goes into that fucking swamp.
And then just Crocodylus oh Jesus
Christ,
the one with the guy hanging the power.
You have a car when you drive in and
those guys and hanging the terminals.
And they showed a guy doing something
and the bolt just blow them up and him
just like his head going on fire.
It was just dropped dead.
God,
they showed the monkey and China,
will you go into a restaurant and you
get hit him in there?
Yeah,
that's awful.
No one wants to tantric ritual where
they said that they said that.
So that one's fake.
There was a few of those did they did
with a stage stuff where they pretend
uh,
pulling out the guts that was like
starting fake and cheesy.
But at that point,
monkey was really screaming,
man.
They were hitting him in the fucking
head.
God Damn.
That's a hard thing to the way that's
all.
Before they knew that eating primate
brains is like super bad for you.
Is it?
Fuck yeah.
He primates have prions in their brains.
That's where you get mad cow disease
like mad cow disease or Jacob.
Jacob how?
How are you saying that disease comes
from eating the same tissue as the
species that you are.
So that's why cows get it.
Cows get from eating brain tissue of
other cows like you feed cows.
The like.
That's one of the horrible things about
industrialized farming is they would
actually take whatever the fuck is left
to the cow they're not using and they
grind it up and feed it to fucking cows.
Cows that are straight vegetarian that
are only supposed to be in grass.
They're not even supposed to eat corn.
When we eat corn,
it fucks them up and they're feeding
them cow brains.
They're feed them their own bodies.
It was hard and that's what gets in and
that's how they got mad cow disease
spreads.
That's okay.
You can raise your good.
My mother used to slice them thin rather
than with Italian progresso and deep
frying God damn fucking lemon.
My uncle vinny used to cook them on the
grills.
Any hold up brands?
Brands,
brands have a cow.
Cats.
Oh Shit.
That's such a small scoop of cat.
A cat guy.
No,
no.
Oh my God.
My mom used to slice those cat cow.
We used limit on them.
If I give them to you and go,
go ahead and eat that chicken cutlet,
you'll go joey,
this shouldn't call it,
so I have a fuck of that.
Chicken cutlets,
calves,
brands.
He'll probably throw a cow brains.
It's good,
but it's really good.
We won't leave this guy.
Don't feed it to another cow.
And there's a thing called prions and
those are what the problem is.
And these prions.
Here's what's really crazy.
It's almost like nature has a foolproof
way.
There's Catholic pranks.
Nature has a foolproof way of making
sure it fucks you up with these prions
because he's.
Prions can exist at a thousand plus
degrees for a long time,
so you can't cook them out like they.
They exist at a temperature way above
anything you've ever been to expose your
food too and they can,
I think find out how long prions can
exist at over a thousand years.
That's something stunning like hours,
hours at a thousand degrees,
so you're not going to kill them,
so if you've got them in your food,
if you're eating and where they found
this also not just in mad cow disease,
but in New Guinea,
in cannibals,
when they find cannibals,
they exhibit the same sort of
neurological issues where their whole
body starts shaking.
Like with Jacobs,
Clark's felds is.
It's like a lot like Parkinson's,
like they start fucking shaking.
It's an.
It's a neurological disease that those
prions from eating brain matter from
human beings,
it actually gets into your system and
just fucks you up.
Apparently.
You can eat meat though.
You can eat human meat.
It doesn't do any.
You're fine.
Yeah.
It's human brains is the real issue.
It's just who the fuck is he in human
brains?
A lot of people,
man,
I mean there was one of the best
evidence,
best pieces of evidence that human
beings homosapiens preyed on the
undertones.
It was finding neanderthal brains,
our skulls with their brain scooped out.
They had scratch marks on the inside
where people are scooping out the
brains.
They had spoons,
they had rocks that whatever the fuck
they could use to scoop stuff up,
but they're scraping.
You know when you're getting a brain,
there's that connective tissues,
the shit that all goes wrong when you
get knocked out too many times and that
connective tissues,
this fibrous matrix that holds the brain
in place and they're scraping that shit
away with a rock as gel that covers your
fluid fluid.
But there's also like tissue.
There's scratches and shit,
you know,
knows it's tools.
It's like deep bone scratches,
gnarly as well.
They figured out.
They know the difference between what
the characteristics of,
of,
of predatory stuff like,
like an animal that's like gnawing on
bones and real obvious slices that came
from like a,
like a tool.
Like when when human beings made lowe's
flint tools and shit like that.
So they've done enough of those tests
were these archeologists can examine
these flint marks on bones and with a
very high degree of certainty tell
whether or not someone's using a flint
tool on bone,
whether or not they're using.
You know,
what's one of the more interesting
things about Egypt.
In fact,
it's because there's some artifacts in
Egypt that are so perplexing.
When I had John Anthony West on the
podcast,
he and I had some conversations about.
It was really interesting because they
don't know how the fuck they carve these
things out.
There's these,
there's some vases,
vase,
um,
that they made out of stone that exhibit
like,
well,
looks like someone cut them with a
diamond,
like some diamond headed drill.
Like they don't.
They literally don't know how they did
it because it's missing all the
characteristics of a that you would
normally get from someone making
something like this.
Like the,
the hole at the front is too small and
it goes inside and it's all smooth
insides.
Like how the fuck did they did this?
They did it all out of stone.
They carved out a one piece of stone so
they can see stuff like they found some
other things,
different holes in things that they're
pretty sure like some,
they use some sort of a,
if not a diamond drill,
like some kind of a drill with an
incredibly hard tip,
but so they know.
They know that people were eating
neanderthal brains,
which is fucked up.
Fucked.
It's fucked up,
but it makes sense.
You know what I mean?
We know the Donner party,
they fucking hate each other and they
knew each other and they ate each other
about that lily alive plane that went
down to Argentina.
Yeah,
Dude.
You get hungry.
You do whatever the fuck you gotta do to
stay alive.
If we go down and play there when be
started looking at me and shit like,
oh Joe,
you got some good ribs.
How long it takes?
How long?
How many days of no food does it take
before you start looking at other dudes
and you're like,
damn.
Yeah,
like his shoulder starts looking good.
Well,
it's also like if
you were with your friend and you were
like trapped somewhere,
you would have to think like,
okay,
if I eat this dude,
I have to live with that for the rest of
my life.
Like even if you guys drew straws,
like you said,
okay,
one of us going to live when I was going
to die.
If I come up short,
I'm jumping off this fucking cliff.
You climbed down the bottom and eat me.
Like you make an agreement with someone
who's so gangster,
they actually fall through that Matt
Brown type character.
Right?
So if you did do that,
like you probably were going to die
anyway eventually.
Like,
and then on your way,
you'd be so ridden with guilt and even
if you made it,
even if you made it home,
you'd be fucked for the rest of your
life.
Like what kind of a life do you even
have now that you ate your buddy?
That'd be a good time to know Jujitsu,
right?
In a plane crash and Sir you're trying
to survive up in the mountains that
there's 20 people.
It'd be for a while.
You just put a little children,
no fucking Jujitsu game eating after 21
days without foods.
When you start getting fucked up,
that's that naked.
Afraid yet three days with water.
Twenty one without food,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
you're fucked up pretty much right away,
but your body goes into a state of
ketosis that he eats off as much fat as
you have.
The more fat you have,
the better you know we don't think about
that.
What are carbohydrate rich diets?
Leave this.
What are you showing me?
Jamie?
Survivals last resort.
In the case of one group adrift in a
lifeboat,
hundred 16 passengers,
116 days passed without food before the
party turned to eating human flesh.
In most cases,
anything even remotely resembling food
was first eaten.
Dogs candles,
leather shoes and blankets are all
consumed first before cannibalism
becomes the only recourse for survival.
Leather shoes.
The shoes and blankets,
blankets,
eat it.
Oh Jesus.
That's dark you.
What you do is you rear naked,
choke one dude and just say,
hey,
look.
Fucking had a heart attack,
and then you always have another body
and you're in charge of that.
Bob,
you're fucking choked them out.
If you choke him out,
his body goes into fucking.
The meat's going to be tough.
You know what I'm saying is that when
you shoot it the wrong way,
so you've got to let them die of natural
causes.
Then the meat tender,
then you cut a little slice off a leg.
I thought you were going to kill this
guy and on.
I'm killing them with kindness.
Kindness to this tab,
and then the meat is gave me,
gave me.
My buddy called me some guy,
go see you in Colorado.
He invented a bullet that hits the duck.
It has marinated in it.
Why have you heard about or I sweat a
lot.
It has a marinades Teriyaki or something
for duck that when you shoot the gun,
as soon as you hit it goes in it.
I swear to God,
so ridiculous.
Something crazy.
I don't think that would work but yet.
But I go,
he's done Denver this weekend.
Go see him.
He goes bad.
But the thing about marijuana is rotten.
Yeah,
that's a good point to know what the
fuck it was.
It was marinated the capital peppers
here and we're in a fixed.
You've got to keep the bullets in the
freezer.
I think.
Sounds like a bad business plan though,
Julia.
It sounds like a dude is high on meth
and comes up with a wacky idea that's
not going to sell.
Come on Rogan.
I get these teriyaki bullets.
You have to do shit cannibalism.
Shoot him with a Teriyaki bullet,
but marinade is like if you marinate the
steak,
you need to like a pan.
You fill it up with marijuana and you
lay it in there and the idea is that
slowly works its way into the muscle.
Soaks in over like a day or two.
The doc,
he's up in the end.
By the time you get to him,
two days later,
be content spread though.
Let's get the party started.
I see that.
You see that fight?
Yeah,
man,
he's amazing and here is no joke.
First big test.
First real test for chrome.
Yeah.
Why don't you see if he could find that
online?
Because I've only seen the finish.
I love the way.
Trap the leg and caught him when he was
trying to drop stomps on them and stuff
and he's off his back.
The whole rising card was sick.
It was a great card.
He pulled guard three times.
Why not freak people frown upon it?
Well,
but he's another one like we're talking
about.
That's an elite specialist in this one
area,
you know.
I mean he's not fighting anywhere in UFC
type mean close was that I thought was
45.
40th five.
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure that was 45.
I was like 55 or seven.
That's Japan.
So he might've weighed 45 cards.
My weight one 80 that a grandma fight
gabby for God knows that like 55 or 65
probably walks at one 80.
Abu Dhabi one 70.
What do you think?
He walks around and he walks in one 70.
He's,
he's.
He has size one 80.
But when we had him on the pockets,
he didn't seem that big.
He didn't seem one a.
But he did seem one 70.
But I could be wrong.
You know what?
He could be one 70,
75.
Jamie,
what a well out Jamie.
I'll find out for us.
Look at him.
He's got a t shirt.
I'm looking.
Wow.
Fighter in the kid.
Tee Shirt by the kid.
Jamie.
I'm powerful.
Um,
it's,
it's good that they had that car,
but didn't they have that card over
three days?
Is that what happened?
They had the heavyweight tournament over
the three days.
Terrible for your brain.
Not for Cro.
Cop for the pride festival.
It's like a weekend thing.
It's awesome.
It's really from that movie warriors.
The only time that existed in real life
up until these guys were getting fucked
up.
Except for Cro.
Cop,
Cro,
cop 42.
Who did he beat?
King Mo time.
That all the time.
King Mo.
Father time that iranian monster gas.
Irene,
how did he knock him out?
Caught up with the leFt hand.
Oh king.
But the left hand to it.
Fucking mop.
But some kicks to the body.
Oh,
nas.
Through some heat.
He looked in a cro.
Cop can go back to his old ways.
You know,
there's no usada in Japan.
As a matter of fact,
they encourage it though,
lIke hop on buddy,
just like,
what are you doing?
They both weighed in at 1:44
point four.
Caligiuri weighed 144 point four.
So basically 45 in Japan.
You get suspended for not doing
steroids.
Yeah,
no,
it's crazy.
So crone is fighting at 1:45.
Yeah,
he's a small dude.
Listen,
how crazy would it be?
He got to the fight to the ground so
easily by just pulling guard.
There's no way he was going to take him
down.
Caligiuri has got some serious
wrestling.
He's a tough motherfucker,
dude.
How crazy would It be?
Etc.
Crone in the fucking ufc.
That'd be sick.
He's oh no,
five years.
No.
But here's the thing.
It will trap that leg.
Really nice.
Look at that.
Beautiful jar.
Very attractive.
He trains with the right camp to do it
too.
Yep.
What'd you train?
We train them as jake shields.
The diaz brothers.
Jake shields got um,
he lost to john fitch yesterday.
I pulled guard right there.
No problem.
Big decision.
Look at 46,
49 when he's bored.
He likes getting into second side guard.
I call,
I call it the cliff,
but it's like a side thing.
It's,
it's,
it's a good position to get good at.
Woo.
Good dexterity of that right leg.
Okay.
Sneaks that right leg in and gets that
butterfly under the armpit.
But if you go back back up a little
jamie,
watch how he does that.
Such a wiki is.
He has them right there with jamie.
Let's get rid of that tv this week.
We have this classic piece.
Images are right here,
dude.
Yeah,
against the ropes and that forever shit
right here,
dude.
They'll get it.
He's thinking.
This is where I saw a crowd rise right
here.
Tell jewish.
No punk either.
Yeah.
This is this test we can.
I'm trying to flip up and you know what?
He didn't even try to take him down.
He just kept pulling guard on them
beCause they get this couch gum to the
day.
Okay.
Kelly.
Julie tried to kick him in the face from
there and then he went.
How did it get us back here?
It's a compilation.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Crones,
jujitsu is just so next level and
compare to these guys.
So there's no,
you know,
when you're fighting mma guys like these
guys,
they're just not going to have the same
kind of technique that he has,
you know,
and he's,
he's gonna have to get there though.
I mean,
you see,
look at the acute stand up and take
down.
No problem.
I'll fight you off my back.
You know,
the ufc right now,
it'd be a little tough for him,
but fuck yeah,
it would be.
He's obviously on the right,
but the cool thing about pulling guard
and having a guard good enough to make
it a good idea.
If yOu could do it at any time to
anybody trapped it again,
that same way he catches that leg when
the guy tries to Kick him and cower.
Jerry's got wind that again and we say,
we cut that leg.
Let's see a little Bit before that.
Before that right there.
Who catches it,
wraps it up with his legs and then use
it to sweep them.
Beautiful.
Was his dad in his corner?
Oh yeah,
go ahead.
Jen was in the corner.
This is classic as shit right here,
man.
And I'm mad at the army green gloves
rising.
Yeah,
that's kinda cool.
Yeah.
Um,
I just think that.
I just hope they don't continue with
that three man.
Three days.
His right arm,
the right arm.
What it does right here.
It's not doing anything to defend.
Look,
it's not really doing anything like that
in trouble.
It's not doing anything,
but it's like just hanging out his right
arm.
He kind oF just look at that shot.
What are you?
Look at that shot.
You got to put your hands,
dad fujita.
Yes.
I mean not for gita.
That's legit man.
This is a big statement for chrome.
Yeah.
Crazy man.
And what's really interesting is like if
he keeps going,
you know,
a couple more fights and continues with
his standup training,
you could easily see him fighting in the
ufc in the next few years.
Easily.
Yeah.
He mayBe he stays a rise and they signed
them to an exclusive.
And the gracies in asia have such a big
name.
Yeah,
he's making bank.
He's probably making more money over
there.
Then I'll go through the.
He'd have to go through the small fight.
Uh,
the titan and have to go straight from
this.
Well,
no,
no.
But before,
if he decided to go through the us route
at the beginning,
he couldn't get into the ufc until he
had like four or five five to thrive.
But yeah,
I bet I bet they'd sign him.
No,
not right away with no fights.
No chrome?
No.
They wouldn't sell the garcia.
Why would it do?
But I think they would do that.
I'm saying chrome right now if.
Can you.
What are you guys talking about?
Beginning of his career before he
started?
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about he went this way.
It's a smart way tO go.
he went,
he fought,
aNd one fc.
I think it was maybe.
Maybe iT's like we would all be better
off.
Everybody will be better off if rise and
continue to blow up.
If they continue to blow up.
It'd be just like pride in the ufc back
in the day,
be great for everybody if they develop
some sort of fate or type character,
you know,
if someone comes along that is like a
legit consideration,
like he fade or my opinion is the only
consideration for not only best pound
for pound but like best heavy weight
ever.
THat didn't fight in the ufc.
Oh yeah.
He's the only one.
I can't think of another one.
I think brides an bella tour,
if you,
if you have those three,
if you have those three big dogs where
even if american fighters want to stay
in american fight and not be in the ufc,
you need bella to develop.
You've got to pay attention to one fc
two.
Yeah,
I mean that's a whole.
That's has nothing to do with Japan.
Southeast asia as a whole.
It's a whole.
Franklin runs ebis me.
He's got some rich franklin shot tree.
No real big exeCutive job though.
Not.
What's the situation with cyborg at this
point?
To check out again,
no good waiting for.
To see what the commission does,
what kind of suspension she's going at
least a year,
at least.
What she pissed hot for is also an anti
androgen.
It's dyo has a dht inhibitor.
I used to rub that shit in my head to
prevent hair loss.
They might give it.
And it's also used by people that take
steroids to diminish the effects of,
um,
of like when females take steroids,
diminish the effect.
it's also a,
it's a masking agent.
So if you take steroids,
some people take that stuff as a mask.
She's 31.
It's also a diarrhetic.
So it's a very weird drug called
spironolactone dean lactone,
but it has many different uses if she,
if she gets three years,
that's what meant.
That sounded good argument.
All the arguments that she gave her,
not good arguments that she took
something out of competition that she
was told bY her doctor that will be okay
when it's clearly on the usada banned
list.
It's 100 percent band.
It's not like there's certain things you
could take out of,
out of context,
like the big ones pot,
like say if they catch you tomorrow and
you're supposed to fight in six months
and you're smoking weed like crazy,
and they test you and they go,
look,
we got to test you,
go look,
I just want to let you know,
but smoke a lot of weed.
They're like,
okay,
as long as it's not steroids,
that's what jon jones didn't get in
troUble when he pissed hot for cocaine
three weeks out of the fight with daniel
cormier because that's not in
competition and it's not a performance
enhancing drug.
He's Just partying.
Right?
So what this is though is a performance
enhancing drug,
not just a performance enhancing drug,
but problematic in that it inhibits its
performance enhancing in,
that works as a diuretic and you're not
allowed to use diuretics,
but it's,
it also inhibits your,
um,
the,
their ability to detect steroids in you.
She's in trouble.
She wAs in the truck you saw that's
going to eat her ass.
And if she gets three years,
well,
here's the thing,
how old is she?
She's in her mid thirties.
Third day they started to get tested her
because she passed on three world title
fights.
They had three world title fights lined
up for her at 1:45,
which is the way class that she asked
for that.
She said she couldn't make it in eight
weeks and so then they gave her more
weeks and they gave her.
They gave her a third test and then like
sums up and whether or not they were
going to test her anyway.
Who knows?
But that's when they tested her and
that's when she pissed hot.
It makes sense.
And she did not reveal before that that
she was taking that and then she does
the whole thing is a.
He's in trouble man.
There it is.
Have you seen escaping all babies?
Skeptical baby now.
So basically that it was so funny.
He was like bitch.
Like that skeptical snake.
So skeptical with sideburns.
Super scheduled.
Have you seen the skeptical house?
No.
Motherfuckers so skeptical.
Skeptical,
skeptical,
cadillac.
So ridiculous.
Cadillac house.
What the fuck is so is that a real
house?
yes,
those are windows,
but the window is that window.
Do you think they did that on purpose
held what's wrong with people?
It almost seems like that was an
accident.
It's so funny,
but with sideboard,
she.
She gets three years.
She's in trouble.
I find the answer to when ronda lost
again and she's throwing shade at ronda,
I'm like,
bitch,
you.
You just got busted for steroids.
Steroids.
She got busted for a dihydro
testosterone.
No,
no,
no.
It's not a precursor.
It's a dihydrotestosterone inhibitor.
That's what it is.
Inhibitor and to me,
my brain goes,
you're in trouble.
You're in trouble.
She certainly could be in trouble.
It's one thing if she got it,
she said was she's got a bunch of issues
because she really did record body
getting down to 1:40,
which happen,
which I'm sure that that seems fine when
you wreck your body,
like I think she's saying that she takes
him too much water down or bodies like
trying to hold onto water and that they
gave her a drug to diminish the amount
of water.
I talked to a couple of doctors about
this.
I asked them questions and they all gave
me that snake face in there.
You know her background too.
It's like,
fuck man,
he don't fuck with anything that's
illegal and you definitely don't fuck
with anything that people use because
they're women that take steroids.
Even if it's just a coincidence that you
happen to be.
You should look at every fucking label.
Extremely careful.
Is that the worst of all time?
Yeah,
that's one of them.
What do you mean cut?
But here's the thing,
man.
Sanchez,
diego sanchez made 1:45.
He fought and won 85 in ultimate fighter
one.
Kenny florian.
Here's the problem.
She fucking dead lifts 305 pounds a
couple of weeks after passing on fights.
She passes on the fight and then puts up
instagrams of her dead,
lifting massive weight.
You're in,
you know,
it was whoever the fuck handles her
twitter account because I wrote that up
because,
uh,
me and brett akimoto,
we're having a discussion about it on
twitter.
Very good dude.
We were having a little back and forth
on twitter about it.
And uh,
you know,
he said,
isn't it weird that she's not fighting
for the title?
And I'm like,
what's weird is that they pack that,
she passed on title fight and then post
instagram photos of her dead lifting.
And then she responded that it's just
like what football players do when
they're not in camp.
Excuse me.
The other day,
and I'm like,
what you saw the golden snitch was like,
what?
What would you say?
She's not writing.
Now I'm looking at the,
the english is perfect.
I'm like,
this is not sisters.
Whoever works with her or her boyfriend
or whoever the fuck handles the
instagram account.
I'm like,
that's no excuse.
There's a lot of maintenance that you do
that's not dead lifting.
Three hundred and five fucking pounds.
You do that to put on mass.
That is why you deadlift you dead lift
to put on fucking mass.
She's got muto mass.
He's got plenty of mass.
She has no problem with mass.
You know what I mean?
That's not what she needs.
If she really wants to fight at 145
pounds and she needs more than eight
weeks to make the weight,
she would.
She should be doing as long term cardio
too though.
Jo.
She goes,
I do that.
And then the morning I run every morning
though.
Dude,
come the fuck on those.
Those aren't as heavy as they learn.
Develop that power.
Sun light.
No,
that's 300 something pounds.
So that's 300.
Five pounds bro.
That's what she's doing.
This is youtube.
Why did she tag she?
Gabby.
That's worse.
Gaby,
to start curling that shit.
You have the same doctor?
I dunno.
fuck.
Say,
look.
The whole thing is awful.
It's awful.
I,
whoever the fuck was in her corner that
let her post that video.
I'd be like,
hey,
hey.
Hey,
what are you doing with your phone?
What are you doing with your phone?
You're going to put that online.
Get the fuck out.
Give me just the golden snitches.
Literally just waiting.
He's looking at going,
a woman dead lifting 305 for reps were
going there.
Six am tomorrow morning.
Boom.
Look,
it is possible that you could get that
big and that jacked without anything,
but it takes a long fucking time and
that's what you're doing.
That's what you're doing all the time.
If you look at some of those Crossfit
gals that some of those are on steroids,
100 percent,
but some of them are not,
and you can get big if you have the
right genetics and you do that kind of
lifting.
Lifting is for people that want to put
on power.
She's got ridiculous power.
Cyborg has some of the nastiest power
you're ever going to see in women's mma.
Probably the most.
The most.
It right up there with.
Well she has the full range,
like she'll kick you and me you and
punch you and elbow you.
Whereas nunez nunez will kick you hard,
but it's her punches that are fucking
ferocious and she doesn't hit hard and
cyborg.
No way.
So subway hits you like Mike Tyson with
braids.
She hits.
Yeah,
she hits girls,
you see,
seem to shut off the.
She makes worldclass girls would be like
that grandma.
She's a beast.
Muster.
Unfortunate that there's so much
controversy,
like I would love if there was someone
like cyborg with no shade attached to
it,
no weirdness attached to it,
but now she's got these two strikes
against her.
Will Amanda Nunez?
She has no shade.
Yes.
She knocks girls out.
She just.
Merck,
misha tate can tell you probably the
number two most famous girl of all time
in women's mma and it's just merck.
The number one.
There's your star with no shade.
Great person.
It's true.
The other thing that's happening with
the youth now that they're already
coming up without that pride,
we would get a lot of guys from pride
and the beginning of the truce was,
okay,
these new guys,
cody's and these men,
the nunezes tend to come up straight up.
Right?
Right,
right.
They're going to come up the right way,
which iS even scarier.
They're not going to flag.
They're not going to be no drama.
Maybe.
I hope not,
but that's what I'm seeing is he shorter
careers for young generation,
you know,
is uh,
I think you'll remember you're seeing
short careers anyways.
Like to me this,
this,
and I feel the same way as you guys do
with.
It's sad the way rhonda loss what's not
that sad because she had such a great
run.
She was a pioneer.
She was on the mount rushmore of mma in
general.
She goes on mat restaurant.
It's really not that sad.
Like god damn.
What are iconic run man?
Sad is like a guy like more homeowner or
a guy like if Mark Hunt word retire like
that.
Sad people don't have money and fame.
She set man.
it's not that sad.
She did some great shit and great
things.
You know what's interesting here is
going on,
it's like the ronda fans,
they're not mma fans.
A lot of them,
they're ronda fans and so like you see
how they respond to stuff on twitter and
you see like the reaction of the things
that they're saying.
Like it's pretty emotional.
It's very emotional.
It's also almost like they don't
understand.
They don't understand the sport.
You know,
get back on the horse.
Like,
whoa,
fuck the horse.
No,
listen to your mom,
your mom,
your mom saying stop.
Her.
Mom's brilliant.
Yeah,
and her mom's.
Her mom's brutal.
She so brutal.
She says,
she goes,
go.
Let stupid people get punched in the
face.
Sorry.
Stupid people.
Her mom,
her mom's brilliant and she's a doctor
and the good thing for rhonda to out all
of this is she's going to find out who's
in her corner.
There's been.
There's been so many.
Yes.
Miss out is in holiday when you're on
set,
you know that bullshit is your agents.
These other people.
You're working with these other
celebrities.
Toenail.
Good.
Your will.
Now when you lose that,
the phone stops ringing,
the tech stop coming.
Everyone asks you to dinner.
That stuff,
you're going to find out who's in your
corner.
That's probably they might be good for
now.
Let me ask you,
what did you do the last two years?
Because I heard they cut her down and
the other one disappeared.
Who knows?
Who knows what kind of deal she has,
but things definitely dried up
substantially after the holly knockout
because she's not the same person
anymore.
The thing about all those deals is when
you're a winner in hollywood and they
start throwing all these movies at you
and you're some athletes coming over,
it's all predicated on you being that
person that they're selling.
Right?
What are they selling?
They're selling this undefeated women's
ass kicker.
The likes,
if you've never seen before,
right?
Throwing people in their head,
get them in an arm bars.
That's what they're selling.
Well,
that's not you anymore.
Now you Just got smashed by holly and
then smashed again by amanda.
They can't sell your acting abilities to
fit.
She'd.
She'd do roadhouse.
Did she redo?
Roadhouse?
Killed him.
They killed him.
I don't know about any of that stuff.
I just know to,
to his point where it's.
It's almost a good thing for it.
It reallY is,
man.
It's not a sad story.
I don't find it as a sad story.
I really don't.
Well,
it's definitely sad.
She was an angel.
It's disappeared,
bro.
Story came,
leaves all that different.
Do we feel safer?
Tiger woods,
like I said,
when that foundation rocks,
what do you think is different with
tiger's swing?
No,
hold the different tiger woods.
He can get the fuck beat out of them and
48 seconds.
I know and that's fighting,
but what I'm saying is the mentality
changes.
When tiger was unstoppable and he.
Something happened.
He's had that.
He had the scandal,
but then he also had some significant
back injuries.
Correct.
Or what?
Okay.
For better example to your fight
example,
like thaisa.
Yeah.
That's also wear and tear too,
man.
You know,
you can say that.
I got to tell you why I can say that.
One of the reasons why is because the
driver
that I had this weekend in vegas that
took me to the airport was mike tyson's
driver for 17 years and I had a long
conversation.
Cool dude.
I wish I could remember his fucking
name,
so I only met him for the brief brief
ride to the airport,
but he was telling me how fucked up
tyson was after the lennox lewis fight.
He's like,
dude,
lennox lewis hit mike and mike was
fucked up for a long time for that.
And You don't think that you watch a guy
get knocked out.
You watch guy get stopped and you know,
mike was talking after the fight and he
was like,
hey,
you know,
I'm,
I'm done.
It's over and eat and they step back,
but when he goes home and he's alone and
the cameras are off and he's got vertigo
and he's got an equilibrium problems and
his ears won't stop ringing in and his
head won't stop throbbing.
You don't see that he's doing
interviews.
His head's throb and his ears are
ringing and it was no internet back
then.
It's harder.
It's harder to hide nowadays.
You know a way.
Got your daily thing that you do and
everybody that your followers and they
all know your daily thing and you guys
can build the daily things.
All of a sudden he disappeared.
Everybody knows he disappeared.
No one really knew you lost the fight.
You never really see him again.
When you do this,
also like when you're suffering alone,
the only way people find out is if you
talk about it like we don't know what
happens to a lot of these guys after
they get beat the fuck up.
You know?
Here's one,
terry adam,
when terry adam got knocked out by the
wheel kits and barboza the wheel kick
from another dimension.
It was the first wheel kick,
kale in the ufc and the worst we'll kick
kale.
It was fucking horrible and he has never
been the same again because he's still
fight.
yes,
he's fought a few times,
but before that terry adam was a bad
motherfucker.
He waS really good and terry adam was
one of those kids that was coming up
like a lot of other guys in the
division,
you know,
he's looking like he might be a
contender someday.
He's slick.
He's got a good,
you know,
he's got a good boxing kickboxing style.
He's got good submissions.
He works hard.
He's a smart fighter.
He's a good guy.
You meet him,
he's a gentleman.
You're like,
this kid might have real potential.
She just got you get hit with those
goddamn kick and it's life changing and
that's,
that's why to dana's point,
you make as much as you can when you're
there,
you got a domain.
That's why your boy tony first then hold
out and be like,
I need more money.
He could get.
We'll kick the chance of that happening.
Not good.
Hey,
he could get.
We'll kick.
So that's why it goes like,
do I need as much money as possible?
Well against.
He's not going to get.
We'll kick against a off.
But he never changed.
He fights.
He beat them.
You know that barboza was amazing.
I was.
Oh,
tourney some fun.
Tony ferguson is one of my favorite guys
to watch for sure.
He's so fun.
He's a.
He's like You said he's a straight up
and figure it out.
What's going on with that?
Because I saw he posted instagram that
he's in big bear.
He's in big bear with his family.
Enjoying the snow.
Oh,
just chilling.
He's training.
I thought he was going up there to
train.
No,
so I thought it was on a hopeful note
that I know of.
Not that I know of,
but you know what they're trying to do,
what they're trying do.
Although,
and norma met off for a fucking interim
1:55
and I'm like,
how do you have a 1:55
interim when connor?
Just one the 1:55
a week ago.
What about max though?
What about max holloway?
He.
Well,
he's got the interim 1:45
such shit show and holloway is one inter
cars all over.
Nigga murda of his sick.
Sick.
Yeah.
It's a great fight.
ALdo versus.
Well,
especially when you see what happened
with Michael Johnson.
Michael johnson stunned habib,
you know he stung him.
He hit him and stung him.
And Michael Johnson with all due respect
is nowhere near the striker that joseph
aldo is.
Joel dot.
Joseph was on a totally.
Josie is as powerful as johnson
explosive question because he's not as
big.
He's been fighting at 1:45
his whole career and he's going to be
fighting a fucking go rilla they know
russian go really is a difference
between johnson's bottom game and all
those bottom 100 percent.
One hundred percent will be way better.
All those kicks there a giant factor
because if aldo who has amazing takedown
defense,
fucking amazing,
some of the best takedown defense.
So he's also got fucking nasty lick
kicks.
So if number got at off moves at him.
what is this?
Who is this?
Is this.
Will you show me here how beam number
given off slams ufc for lying to the
fans about josie?
Aldo demands relevant fight against
trump.
Why is he saying this line to the fans?
Let's see.
Let's see what he says here.
Oh no,
it'll come back on this.
This goddamn screen dude.
Uh,
it's clear to everyone that you hiding
connor from me.
But stop lying to your fans.
Like I don't want fight with aldo.
I'm ready to fight with anyone in my
division.
Give me relevant fight.
So you won't.
First of all,
take your phone away from your sister.
Somebody.
Somebody's got this phone then making.
No,
he's definitely doing it broke even
though she's so ralph.
But I love it.
It makes it more gangster.
Okay.
You've never matched up.
What is it?
I can't see tHat jamie.
This thing is in front of it.
oh,
you never matched up to guys with nine
and eight winds streak in ufc.
Never in ufc history.
That doesn't mean anything.
See,
here's the problem is too expensive.
I see what he's saying,
but let me explain why it's wrong.
They need big,
relevant fights to sell pay per views.
Right?
And that's all they care about.
Here's the deal.
The ufc was purchased for
$4,000,000,000.
Bill,
imagine if you bought a.
I mean you have,
you own a place in your house.
You know what a mortgages,
mortgages are pretty cunty.
You'll look at them every month and go,
jesus.
Now if you have a mortgage for a nice
house and he spent a million bucks,
that's a fucking nut you've got to make
every month,
man.
You got to think about it.
you've got to go,
okay,
we've got the mortgage is covered.
All right?
And then you move on with all the other
bills,
right?
Tell me about,
it's a $4,000,000,000
house.
What kind of fucking mortgage and how?
How do we pay the bills by doing huge
fights?
Huge.
So we gotta figure some shit in term
interim.
Interim.
Everybody in your belt,
the reality as jon jones is,
and jon jones isn't even the champ right
now,
so when he comes back,
he's not even fighting for a world title
unless he fights for the world title.
So you gotta have dc has got to be
healthy or you got to have john fight
for an interim because they're just
throwing interims out like they're
fucking fliers that they're put on your
car when dudes are trying to like sell
carwash.
Yeah,
and my brother,
they'll start getting these fucking cars
selling.
They've got to be another season.
The fear factor is going to be added on
please.
No,
no,
there's not going to see samsung for
some brad pitch to sell paper or some
shit or something.
I don't know what they're gonna do you
know who knows if I'll be for it,
but when you look at,
when you look at like the,
the,
the title picture,
who that card that they have in
brooklyn.
I mean That is,
that's a pay per view card and it looks
like an fs.
One car right now.
I'm sure they're going to juice it up.
They'll get more,
but it's not a die hard fan.
Pay 60 bucks for that shit.
It's hard.
It's hard to make those cards.
So we.
I think we kind of nailed it when we
were talking about it earlier,
like what guys sell paper reviews.
I think woodley's a bigger star now that
he'd be wonder boy,
but he still wants that.
A big review too in like dana and I were
having this conversation.
It's like you can't have nick diaz.
He goes,
nick diaz doesn't want a fight since
2011.
He can't have him step in and just go
right up to the title and that's what I
said.
I said,
but I want to see it.
He goes,
I want to see it too,
but you Can't sell it will you will.
No one's going to take the sports
series.
So if you give a guy who hasn't won
since 2011 or 12,
give him a title shot.
People fans were like,
come on bro.
But I think they missed the boat if they
wanted to make a fucking big money.
It's nick diaz versus conor mcgregor.
Big brother.
He's trying to fight at one 70 some on.
No,
his.
His brother was too big for him.
You think he's too big?
way too big.
I think that talk is nonsense because
connor's the 1:55
pound champ.
Nate fought at 1:55
most of his career.
He fought at one 70 a couple of times
and he's undersized.
Don young.
Kim beat Him at one 70.
He's a.
He's a legit one.
Seventy year though.
He's 70 maybe,
but he fights 1:55.
Easy look.
Great against Michael Mcdonald at 55.
Tyron woodley if his fucking life
depends on it.
Tyron woodley is not gonna.
Make it $55.
The champ can't make 1:55
at one 70.
Nate,
ken.
So nate is not a real one.
70.
Now here's to your point,
in dana's point,
he doesn't want to fight since 2011 and
ended up connor ger your cash cow fight.
THis monster isn't one forever.
It's a great story.
It really is.
Love big brother's steps in on.
I would watch it,
I'd watch them in,
but to your.
To your point,
they have to figure something out to get
these stars it because you can't do it
overnight.
To me,
it doesn't matter.
You put nick diaz for what he's done out
of respect who's going to complain,
but apparently they offered nick diaz,
robbie lawler and nick passed on it.
That's the word.
That's the word behind the scenes.
Interesting.
Maybe,
maybe I'm not supposed to say that,
but uh,
I wanted to see that fight.
I would love to see that rematch.
But I think nick wants a fucking title
fight,
you know?
I think nick is like,
look,
I want a big,
big name or a title five.
I literally make these demands.
Make nick made some money.
He's not ridiculous.
He doesn't spend it all.
Well,
how about nate?
I'm not,
I'm not answEring the call and this is
20 million.
Yeah.
We talked about.
We talked about that reCently in the
podcast.
I was like,
well,
let's break this down because like,
let's say they do a million pay per view
buys,
which is like top end,
right?
There's only a few people that have ever
sold a millions like brock.
Rhonda conner set a million is top of
the food chain,
so a million pay per view buys at 60
bucks.
That's you're taking one third right off
the bat.
For nate,
it's really hard to jUstiFy giving
someone $20,000,000
to do that.
It's got to be real hard and then
obviously our Could demand.
That is like one of the only guys that
can get that kind of money.
He's the only one.
What are you guys?
You think eventually guys will just
start doing?
I think it's so big.
Like connor,
he just does his own show and he gets
his own people.
No use lawyers are too good to let you
get out of your contract.
They realize that if,
if nate had a legit fight with someone
other than connor,
that was exciting.
The problem is there's no one else in
the division that's got that kind of
marquee value.
YeaH.
There's nO one in the division that has
the kind of marquee value that if you
had a look,
I think nate is a fucking huge star,
but in less than.
Especially now.
I mean,
after he beat conor,
he's one of the biggest stars outside of
that upper echelon,
paperview low level,
but he's not a world title holder right
now.
So if you wanted to really have a big
fight for nate,
I would have him fight a whole tab.
Would work.
That would work.
That would be ever come back.
Gsp apparently they couldn't work out
the deal with the reebok deal.
Like he's got to deal with uNder armor.
He's got a Big deal with under armour.
It makes a lot of money through under
and shit.
Yeah.
And so he couldn't work out a deal with
that was worth it to him.
You know,
there was an offer on the table.
He didn't like it.
They're still talking.
He stIll says he wants to fight,
but if the ufc,
you know that now that they've lost
rhonda,
most likely lost rhonda.
We don't know what happened.
I mean,
you,
she's not the same anymore.
It's definitely,
definitely a tough sell.
But I mean,
who fucking knows a yeaR and a half down
the line,
she's still only 29.
I think she's still get paper views if
she comes back on a year for sure,
but it's not the same.
It's not the same baby.
You sit and money flows like water.
People will not want to watch it even
more,
but she's not fighting anytime sooN so
he can't paint on her as stable going
up.
So you got to move on from it.
She comes.
Great.
Let's keep going.
You know what I'm saying?
You know,
it's interesting,
man.
It's a crazy sport.
It goes up,
it goes down and moves all over the
place.
Every sports like this though.
Here's the other thing.
When's brock Lesnar back?
I mean,
if brock lesnar suspended,
first of never,
that's not true.
Uh,
when,
when they damn it son.
Listen,
he,
he only got suspended for,
for clomifene clomifene.
Even though it is a,
it,
it enhances
steroids,
uh,
your recovery from steroids because it
reduces estrogen psychotherapy for
steroids.
It's,
it's definitely not good.
But it also exists in a bunch of
different supplements,
like over the counter stuff.
Hey man,
are you arguing he wasn't taking?
No,
no,
I'm not.
No,
What I'm saying is how much time do you
think they're going to give him off?
Like how much time are they going to
have times when we let him not do these
tests and beat up a guy,
but.
No,
no,
he will have to do the usada test again.
He didn't get the last time he did it.
They had a couple of exemptions where
they can get in on the four month thing
that they Built in in case they wanted
to make a big fight where they get
signed somebody.
So that one obviously blows up in their
face and he's gonna get suspended.
But how long for how long?
I thought they gave him a year and
$225,000.
Is that what it is?
Pretty sure.
Okay.
So that's from what?
July?
Yeah,
it's all.
It's all retroactive.
So that ain't that long from now.
What's where we were in january,
february,
march,
april,
may,
june six months than the heaVyweight
division needs him.
Jon jones,
first heavyweight fight.
Brock lesnar ba ba ba ba bum bum bum bum
bum,
bum bum.
Yeah.
Imagine that fight.
The only problem is if you think so.
Yes.
Mercury in the grappling.
I think you're just completely died.
Fucking steel.
Brick would fucking ratchet you.
Pissed.
Pissed that mumbles and he'll fuck left
because they'll say it.
You better do the fucking steroids feel.
Pick this crazy motherfucker.
Shit.
I love him.
I love Him to immigrant mentality.
Bringing them on board in America.
Give him more fucking steroids.
what's that?
You want another one in America?
Whatever the fuck.
He was definitely born in cleveland,
Ohio.
That fucking crazy blood in them and he
don't give a fuck croatian listening.
he proved it with fucking overran.
They don't give a fuck.
Put him in there with.
Go ahead.
I gave you the product at all to the
guilt in brooklyn who just ragdoll pull,
pull poor fucking out of mark has never
been the kind of grappling the steepest
just way better.
oh no.
I think steve baY beats.
You know what?
If he punches in the face it's going to
get more steam out of his fucking.
He is and he Won't let his then coming
back thinking that because he's not
going to come back and fight for a world
title right away.
You don't think so?
I think it's the biggest embarrassment
to the lord.
That would be a crazy,
the biggest fucking embarrassment of the
year.
That why would that be embarrassment,
but it was embarrassing.
It's just embarrassing and we've got
smart.
They knew he was on the juice.
He went in there loaded to the gills.
It was just an ambassador.
It was an embarrassing thing for
everybody,
and mark hunted every fucking right to
be mad.
They put them in there with a guy that's
coming off rocket fuel.
That dude don't just only deep ball lift
the sides of his head.
He's taking shit that makes you fucking
had grown fucking pit bulls.
I hope they put them against my yo.
Check.
I will fly the fucking wreck.
Government's climate climate mouth.
I found the snot in my nose that was
bigger than this gum.
The.
I take the gum out there either.
Anyway,
it was so long.
It was like a code book.
I got a flashback from the hell that
motherfucker anyway,
because I love him.
I love him.
From time to time I have a little button
and it just comes out and it's got like
a little clam was on board with you with
all this steve notes from time to time.
Oh,
when you eat,
when you quote for 30 years,
it's a habit.
You wake up in the morning,
pick one out.
It's like a candy cane.
You inhale that motherfucker.
It's like going to the dentist for free.
I will throw up on this fucking table.
Do you ever do that?
To be honest With ourselves.
We're all friends here.
that was the most embarrassing fucking
thing I ever seen.
I agree.
They knew he was on it and they put that
fucking animal in there.
Okay,
and you know what man?
Go ahead.
Keep doing those steroids.
Put them in there against pop whatever.
Cleveland motherfucker just kill him.
He'll fucking kill him in general.
Stupid.
I think they would ever be able to have
him come off a suspension and fight for
the title.
That's not how it goes.
$4,000,000,000
though.
He The scab off of iranians heaD right
now.
Right now.
They're fucking shit.
That gun we lost.
Come out of your mouth.
Dry patient.
Give me a tissue.
Was rhonda and the only other thing we
got his fucking condom.
He's having a baby.
He don't want to fucking come back.
Now you know what he's talking about.
He might come back.
Right?
But they don't want to give them a.
We supposed to fight.
Who is he supposed to be supposed to
fight that fucking collar.
Beat and and stories.
One of them.
Let's do it.
Let's set it up.
No,
that's not.
I'm with joey.
Fuck that.
This shit.
You don't need to find out though.
He don't need to fight nobody.
He's number one.
Right?
Or if it was your boy,
number one.
Tony khabib's number one.
Okay,
then that's the fight enough.
And tony was number one and then khabib
can became number one.
Why did it could be a leap frog.
Tony.
I don't know.
Who knows the rank because he talked to
fought a couple times.
I don't know what his brother khabib's
number one.
Well,
that's the thing he did.
Listen,
he's fighting now.
He's available today.
He's available for brooklyn.
Okay.
He said it when he fought against
Michael Johnson.
He's available for fucking.
Okay.
He's available for brooklyn and let's
get eddie against raphael.
That's a good fight.
Let's get that back in that people like
watching him.
Very.
Let's get it done.
Let's get.
We got some fucking people here.
Okay.
A lot of good guys.
Let's get here.
He south paper views bounce around
300,000,
but he's.
He's robbie lawler.
That got as good.
Fuck it.
They got joey needs to be the
matchmaker.
Fucking got it.
Okay.
Yeah man,
it's an interesting situation and find
out a whole shitload.
Want to give us the fights we want to
see.
No problem.
Don't they want to be.
That's the beep and the story.
There's no outdoor,
no pony.
Ferguson,
and there's no babies.
There's no nothing but he has a.
He's got a baby.
It's not a big draw.
Just fuck.
It sounded like throw 20 million on you.
The baby's weight.
Six weeks,
but canada's already got 20 million.
That's the difference.
He wants to take time that he can.
The breadth of his.
His life is more important than what the
ufc was running the show.
I agree with you on May 5th,
may labor memorial day weekend.
It's called habib habib ferguson before
ferguson ferguson.
Sharon,
let's have some fun.
Get ferguson.
So ron,
let's have some fucking.
Drone is not fighting 55.
Again.
I didn't say that,
but we're all mixing wall mixing weights
right now.
Did we not say that before?
They want to put out against compete,
but know how all those thinking about
moving up and moving up anyway.
So who gives a fuck?
It seems like he's kind of chasing like
a chest if he wants that fight.
Let's.
That's what everybody wants to see you
again,
whatever the fucking orders,
but the order that they're trying to put
together,
it was the order I don't want to see
because they have to sell paper,
but they're going to do this.
Okay.
This is the route you flux,
is that gonna is going to bring him back
against fucking the black dude at one
70.
That's the fight.
Tyron woodley.
That's already been made at the thing
that's going to come to get the fuck
down.
Watch it,
watch it.
Well,
we just said that woodley's going to
fight bisbing to catch what I know.
I know.
That's all great.
They're going to want you think that
tyron woodley is going to fight.
That was already a staff in New York.
Tyrone woodley,
tyron,
tyron will leave.
He's going to fucking fight.
I'm okay.
That's the first fight.
Then they're going to try that.
That's the right thing and to put at one
70 maybe in may.
What happens?
It could be.
Then this is what he used to go to one
sentence.
My decision.
This isn't my decision.
This is beyond you.
This is beyond this because I already
seen the setup at the fucking New York
where you fucking blind because you
didn't see what I see.
I talked to them.
I know you talked to them,
but to tell you the deck that I'm
talking to the people that know this
again,
so you didn't know because I did
understand,
but the problem is here that that was.
The seed was already planted in New
York.
It was already planted.
None of you motherfuckers side.
What do you guys watch?
Let's see what a seed of him talking
back and forth with tyrone.
Tyron woodley.
Okay.
That's the fucking jesus christ.
Fucking shit.
Smells like a zoo.
He's gonna.
Look at you already at the press
conference and people already.
He said,
oh,
he doesn't fight enough.
Okay.
Wait,
what's going on here?
That's wayne's talking shit to seed.
Your dumb fucks happening here.
What is he saying?
He's just talking shit.
You hear what he said?
No,
I don't think so.
It went on and said,
hey,
come out.
Came out like you're lucky.
I don't come to 70.
Hold on.
Look at.
I'm trying to be cute with them as a
moment here.
There's a momentary going between tyron
woodley and it got set up right there.
Each other down the next fucking fight,
conor saying we can do it at 70.
We can do this Job because you see what
you want to fucking see.
That's the next fight.
They already.
He already planted the seed.
He's not going to fight tyrone.
He's gonna.
Fight tyronn and killed one time for
copied like they threw with frankie.
Edgar was fucking working through dennis
receivers available.
Look so good.
The color of his skin so now already
gets.
He's talking to some truth.
It's in between.
He's.
He doesn't want to fight ferguson.
He's dropping a fight.
Tony ferguson.
Why not just grow?
It takes too much height and tony
ferguson don't give a fuck.
He's backstage again in fucking Florida.
That is a horrible for me.
It's just tremendous.
Look at this.
They are going to get some volume on
that.
Can we get volume on that?
What?
You here this go all the way back.
Way back.
There we go.
Crank it up.
He's setting it up.
She up the one that's eight guys did
with that phone.
Whoa.
It's crazy out.
There's 10 guys in the fucking drain.
Tyron looks.
Let's hear.
Let's hear rewinding tech.
We want to.
We want to hear that lady said,
what's up?
And he said,
He said,
not much,
but meanwhile you look at tyron.
Tyron looks so drain there.
When he made that weight is like right
after you made the way he's going to go
for three.
Fuck.
Nobody ever saw this shit.
He doesn't want.
He's not going to fight ferguson because
it's a fucking.
It's a aerosmith.
Guns and roses was aerosmith on steroids
and tony ferguson is little ds with
fucking blood in them.
You understand me?
He doesn't want that.
You don't want tony ferguson and dana.
It's another whole John uncle bobby dana
is not going to let his nephew Fight.
Kidding connor versus is not a draw.
It's not a draw for connor.
he's your guy.
That's a big fucking fight.
Make total
though could be.
Why do you think they're making it?
Eddie?
You tell me.
Why do you think it's not going to sell
and I love these guys.
Don't get me.
I'm not.
I'm not a clown in your guy,
but as far as the average consumer
buying a paper view,
that's not a sell.
It's just not hell.
Yeah,
it is.
I just of fighting somebody buddy cop
top challenger is always a sale and
tony,
but tony ferguson is most certainly a
top challenger.
When nate dIaz fought conor for the
first time,
it was a giant fight because nate diaz
had a name and he's a bit.
He's a bigger name than tony arguably
for sure.
Not even close,
much bigger now after he beat for before
others and tony wasn't the same as it is
now either.
It's a different.
It's a different thing now,
but.
But he had it because of nick and nick
had had all the strikeforce success
elite,
see success,
you know all that is a lot of tv time.
There's the ultimate fighter winner,
nate.
And then on top of that,
nick just got done beaten anderson or
fighting anderson rather.
And you know nick,
nick is like a pretty well known figure.
These brother,
they're both the diaz brothers are like,
so that's a different level.
But having them take that fight on short
notice too.
But connor was the main.
Draws my points because I agree it's,
he's the main draw.
if you're calm and you're his manager,
he'd go on,
let's fight tony,
who's a tough fucking matchup,
but he's not as big as the name as a guy
like nate diaz at 55 who were gonna make
more money,
maybe not as tough as a fight bigger
name,
so they're doing it from a business
point and not fighting,
not fighting khabib.
You also have to fight fightiNg.
Horrible fight for.
They're going to do a Russia card and
when they do a Russia card,
they want to do a Russia card with
connor or with hubby brother.
So when they do a Russia car with habib,
it's most likely going to be for a
title,
I would imagine.
That's what a title it.
It all depends if comment,
except that reminder might be tony and
in my current interim,
and apparently they offered it to tony
and tony said that he wanted to make the
same amount of money that habib bank,
which is perfectly fine at first prep
fine,
but you know,
they said,
nope,
you got a contract.
You've got to honor your contract.
That's at least how it's been explained.
Yes.
That's how it's been explained.
They go,
nope.
Will you sign these contracts?
You got to honor the contract.
Yeah,
but that,
that,
that only works one way.
The only works for the ufc because they
don't honor all the contracts ready me.
If it works for,
they can cut them.
They can.
You have a six week contract plus two,
But that seems to cut.
it's in the contract that you can get
cut if it wasn't in the contract.
There's guys who have fought and they
fought out their entire contract for
sure.
I'm just saying.
I remember the early days and pedro
huizar had this giant contract because
they thought that pedro is going to be
the heavyweight champ and so they were
giving him like undercard fights.
He's making quarter of a miLlion
dollars.
Yeah.
It's tricky man,
because I get the idea that they would
want to protect connor,
you know,
and really set up the big fights.
Especially
now because he's the biggest guy.
But then you've got connor who's kind of
fucking crazy and he's like the way he
was john [inaudible],
he gets caught or don't.
I think from,
from a business standpoint,
they're going,
what's the biggest fight pot?
Let's say you have three fights left.
Who were the three biggest names we can
fight and to make this happen so you
stay undefeated big and make the most
money.
He might not be under feet.
I mean it's definitely not undefeated
now.
Right?
But the biggest thing is the woodley
fight because that's a one seven.seven
seven.
That's a third belt guys.
That's a fight.
As much control on your fuckers up.
You didn't see it.
Number two,
listen,
I'm not saying that khabib is going to
be kind of,
especially after I talked to take the
punch or michael kahn.
I'm not saying michael,
Michael Johnson,
but the fight is khabib and then the
next fight has to be ferguson.
If he beats him,
not just the way it is cooked.
ferguson came.
Wait,
they can't wait like ferguson needs a
fight like in the next four or five
months.
It could be me as a fight in the next
two,
three months.
I don't find in brooklyn from now.
To what extent when you went to viewed
them,
put the hat on your dad.
He said he'll fight and brooke,
we put the hat on my head every time I
put every time right now.
It's great.
I fucking love it.
He looks at me,
shows me that I give him the nod,
like,
yeah,
I'll put that on the flood lights.
That had me as a fan is tony rush.
Can be.
That's.
That's the fight.
That's a fight.
It's not a better match up,
but it can be.
I don't know about that.
I like a tony versus connor.
I even like beef versus connor.
Connor versus woodley.
I like tHat fight to fight gun.
That's the next money fight,
but he's going to eventually use.
Gives them enough power to do that.
I get that.
Yeah.
He's got all the files.
Well,
here's the thing about do more
powerfully loses to bisping.
If he loses those catch weight fight,
he still keeps that $170 strap.
That's if that catch weight.
That's just use my.
No,
you can't hold two divisions.
I run against my boy.
I'm telling you.
They going after tyro.
Planted the seed right there.
Who can't tie up to division.
I've been backstage at ufc is all the
guys like,
dude,
throw away from the russian as long as
they can,
but specifically we can talk over each
other.
No,
they'll do the nasa thing.
When they go to interview him,
they'd die in car accidents and shit,
but that's the fight guy.
So that's the fight right there that
everybody wants to see right off the
bat.
I love to see conor and could be by love
to see ferguson and khabib,
but they don't really do that rIght off
the bat.
They're going to hope that they fall off
a cliff or a plane goes down.
let's give him the money for it,
which is one sentence.
Kenny,
get the third belt.
Here's the thing,
if he does lose,
if he goes up the risk for it.
Same thing with that.
Nate first.
Nate diaz number.
Who runs this shit?
Do you do.
What do you do
with tony and khabib?
They go to hell.
No,
fuck you.
Ufc.
We can't take this.
No more.
Good from us.
Here's another thing at beltour,
there's still one guy left that I don't
know where his contracts at,
but Michael Chandler is a motherfucker
will fuck.
He is a motherfucker.
He's remarried.
He beat eddie alvarez.
Who was the champ at 1:55.
Did you see?
We did want that pit bull guy and starts
to him with one punch them.
Dude.
MIchael chandler is legit as fuck.
How many fights do you have left though?
I don't know.
It's interesting.
He was just at the ufc the other day.
That's why I'm saying it,
ross.
I was talking to him.
I didn't talk to them about the fight.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker to another guy.
Lance palmer from team alpha male who's
series.
He has one fight left and after that
he's going straight to the use.
Good luck being that motherfucker.
What way to say 45 can wrestle his balls
off.
Hm.
Interesting.
Yeah.
There's a lot of talent coming up,
man.
Lot of talent coming up.
then you have some interest or like the
lorenz larkin,
who's a month is he to go to belterra?
They're talking to me.
He's a free agent.
I hope he stays in the ufc.
I really do.
Because you're paying pretty good.
Yes.
They have to.
They have to throw it is the,
you know,
the people are going to get over there.
Only mcdonald's lark in the lenses on
there yet.
But lorens the way he put away neil
magnet.
I was like,
don't go anywhere man.
Stick around like lorenzo lorenzo beat
robbie lawler.
Lorenzo is legit as fuck.
Nightmare.
He's a dangerous striker.
He's one of the best records in that 170
pound division and fought a good chunk
of his career at one 85.
One seven.
And he's a big fella and he's got a
ridiculous kicks.
He throWs that goddamn oh bleak kick to
the body better than anybody I've ever
seen him pull up the fight.
Uh,
lorenzo larkin versus neil maGni.
Neil magnet,
who is a tough fucking dude.
You didn't even have a chance in that
fight.
Starch.
He beat Johnny Hendricks.
The judge's helped,
but he beat.
Neil went in one and three in the.
I think he could have been conceivably
one because of having them in that
triangle in the third.
But the first round was so loose,
it just didn't look dangerous to me.
That was like a legit loose triangle.
But he.
But he still did more than john's muscle
biases fucked.
Who might be right.
I just have to look at it again.
But I,
I saw some,
I saw some space and I think the arm was
tucked in enough where I don't think
johnny was like in real trouble,
but he was definitely stuck thinking
about those judges though.
They don't know shit.
They see him in danger.
They're given some serious motherfucking
danger anytime you're caught with one
arm and one on the mount and the shit as
cinched.
It's almost like your legs are so long
that like he gives you a little extra
space because his legs are so long was
the problem was pushed down and started
throwing elbows.
And when that does like his hands and
there,
it pushes them out.
yeah.
That's what happened.
So the more you hit them.
So it's like you gotta you gotta couple
farting up a storm.
Like you got to land a couple of elbows
and then grab the wrist and pull them
back in.
You got to constantly pull back in,
throw a couple more like this and yeah,
but they remember.
You're pushing them out of your shit.
Remember when anderson stopped travis
luder.
That's how he got them locked him up.
DOn't miss.
Wait,
could there have been a more frustrating
cut?
He didn't.
Just ms dot dude was the closest I've
ever seen.
Where we're looking back.
The guy was dead.
Watch thiS fight.
Here's the lorenzo.
Lorenzo is a slick striker,
but watch this oblique kick to the body.
a lot of guys are throwing this to the
leg,
but lorens throws it to the body and he
switches stances a lot.
But the way he lands it launches you
through the air with it.
so he hits him with that low kick,
low kick on the bottom of the calf,
like real low.
It's going to happen right now.
It's going to happen.
I mean,
this is just the fight itself,
but the way he throws it is really
unusual man,
because he'll be like from here,
like right there.
That's it.
yeah.
You see that?
Yeah.
That's exactly.
Or rear push.
Yeah.
no,
no.
Watch,
watch.
It's the oblique kick.
Watch.
See that?
This is what he wants.
No,
no,
no.
It's not.
It's like this.
He's doing this.
Watch it again.
Back it up and just watch it.
Just watch it.
Trust me.
I know what the kick is.
Watch how he does it.
Watch.
Whereas he lists his toes are pointing.
See his toes are kind of pointing it now
outside.
That fucks me up.
Oh dude.
it's a.
I'll show you on a Bag.
It's a devastating j.
Neil.
Talk about the fight.
He goes,
I literally just overlooked the guy.
He doesn't get a lot of hype,
but he definitely should.
What?
Overlooked.
Larkin.
Yeah.
He goes,
he goes,
there's just.
I don't know.
He,
he doesn't get a lot of hype.
Thought it was going to be an easier
fight than it was.
Well,
he just got off a beaten hector lombard.
He might've been feeling his oats.
Yeah,
exactly.
But larkin is a totally different
animal.
He's probably the most hot.
He's tough.
One of the most technical and a capable
guys in the division.
When it comes to striking his jujitsu
again,
you see it again,
like I said,
again,
reducing his foot is not.
He's hitting with the heel like this.
It's like this is.
This is what he's doing.
See how he does it there,
dude.
Come on.
Sign who kicks like that?
Like again,
back that up again.
We're going to extension.
He gets.
Watch this.
Watch how he throws this cake.
This is a beautiful kick man.
He sets it up with that and then steps
in spartan style food.
It's.
It's a weird kick because a lot of guys
don't do it the way he does his stomping
and john does it all the time.
Yep.
But john does it to the legs.
It a lot to ronda.
Holly did it to rhonda.
That's wiggled in instead of out.
Right?
Exactly.
It's like you step forward and you do
this and it's got all the boys in front
of a bag,
I'll show you is the ufc.
I knew he didn't invent it,
but they've been doing it forever
forever,
but they weren't doing it to the leg.
Not to this degree though.
He fucking sparta kicks.
The rens is on another level.
He just is and the only loss that he has
inside the octagon and one 70 is against
human off and that was a super close
fight and he's not so he's not the only
guy that ever let him throw it exactly
like that.
He's one of the only guys have ever seen
throw it to the bottom and knock someone
down and the way he throws it to the
body,
just massive power and speed the way he
chambers his legs and then gets that
kick to launch straight in a straight
line practices that right.
The guyS are doing now to guarantee
issue with this success kind of cat
league.
You have to see a thousand times before.
People don't make it part of their daily
routine,
but he's fucking strikes.
Lorenzo flies under the radar like he
Wants more publicity.
They did it again.
He did it.
He does it from here to the body,
which is so crazy nasty.
Can you imagine him versus Roy
Macdonald?
Bellatore I could.
Oh no,
but I can imagine him fighting for the
title against woodley too.
I want to see him at one 70 in the ufc.
I was selfish.
What's his last record of the last?
The last one off.
And it was a razor close decision that
recent,
uh,
that was like two or three fights ago
and he's won all the other ones.
He's a monster on a winning streak.
YeaH.
But this is the big win because
magnesium a top contender and he beat
the fuck out of magna.
Magna was never in this fight.
This fight was,
it was like he worked.
A man magnet has really only been out
class in this larkin fight.
And then he got out class when he fought
demian maia larkin throws a lot of weird
shit to throw,
like we'll kicks to the thigh.
Did he came into rain and everyone was
like,
well,
we don't know what the fuck to do.
Really.
There's no.
Me and pat couldn't get them down.
Is take down a fence.
Was ridiculous.
His striking was unconventional.
He was a nightmare.
Yeah.
He's got a,
I think a kung fu background.
I think that's where he started his
career,
but you see like that low leg kick,
man,
he likes he attacks like below the knee.
We can Just do it again.
He'll up.
As far as the sweet spot with the take
down defense to speed magnet pulls.
Guard.
Yeah.
I bet.
It's interesting being a guy of his
caLiber going,
god,
do I go to bella tour where I make more
money or do I stay in the ufc?
Why could actually be a ufc champion?
And you know,
the notoriety that comes with that.
It's like,
it's a tough fucking.
You know what I'm saying?
The problem is you could go to bell tour
and he could chew away years of your
career and no one will know who you are.
You know,
look at diego lima,
you know,
or Douglas Douglas lema.
I know,
I'm just kidding.
No,
no,
exactly.
No lima's a world will look at Michael
Chandler.
Yeah.
Michael chandler.
It.
I mean he's better.
Maybe alvarez.
Alvarez.
Yeah.
Still.
I mean you,
you,
you talked about a guy like of that
caliber.
He walks down The street in the seVen 11
people are.
Well,
what are you a crossfit?
They don't know who he is.
what happened?
He was in the ufc.
Everyone knows who he is.
Yeah.
No,
you're right.
It's not there yet.
I Wish they can get there though.
We don't know man.
They don't have paper view.
they don't have like those you need
spike tv.
It's not the same.
It's just what they're putting.
I w I agree,
but they,
they've tried one paper view was a
terrible disaster.
Who was the paper?
You the rampage.
Remember?
I do remember me.
Just mark.
Nobody bought it.
It's just,
it's.
There's a difference.
But their ratings on regular cable.
Good.
Just as good as the use.
What's weird is their ratings on regular
cable still don't translate into
stardom.
It's very strange.
It's because I think what they've been
doing is they've been getting the older
guys from the ufc where people are like,
oh,
he's kind of over the hill where now
they have a guy like Roy Mcdonald who
was young and he can be that kind of
world class athlete,
but the replay of a wonderboy fucking up
rory.
That's what they show over and over and
over agaIn,
and then they show robby lauer knocking
out rory and they'll just show it over
and over again in their highlights
through till everybody knows rory left
and went over there.
I look,
I wish nothing but the best until it
gets like a michael venom page.
Let's say he just.
If they get one superstar like a jon
jones who started with them,
then you're going to start seeing some
gnh got kind of exposed in his last
fight.
What happened on the distance did knock
the guy out,
didn't really look that good and he's
the answer,
but I'm saying they need a type of guy.
I forget who he fought because the the
chill zone in versteeg ortiz.
It'll do record breaking.
It's going to kill number wise because
we know who those guYs are both older.
Oh,
it's going to sell for sure.
Well,
what's not selling?
It's going to be a regular tv,
right?
It's not paper view.
What?
No,
I'm gonna say it's gonna sell ticket
wise at the time.
Because remember,
remember that brooklyn card was supposed
to be at the same time as as that a belt
or card use left because they didn't
have a headliner for that.
So they left anaheim.
Remember that same night?
Is that where it was?
Oh,
well that's the brooklyn card.
They moved back to brooklyn.
That's what happened.
Oh,
it's interesting that brooklyn card does
look like they're still working on it
though.
I'm hoping that they could pull that.
It's a smart room because like tito
chill and we got fucking holly this like
it doesn't.
So that's the same weekend.
Yep.
So the remainder randomly.
No,
I think they switched it,
but it was the same as bellatore belt
towards January 21st on spike.
Oh,
okay.
So february.
And they switched it to that february.
Can dos santos rescheduled that?
No,
we'll do for doom.
Was supposed to fight cain,
but cain got pulled off the card because
she fucked up man.
He did an interview and said that he
needed surgery after the fight and they
were like,
what?
so you know bob baker from the Nevada
state athletic commission who does
fucking awesome job.
He is not going to let you fight.
If you go around telling people that you
need surgery,
what's your liability?
It's a liability business.
One-on-one came and you just can't do
it.
He fucked up.
He probably didn't think about it.
He just thought,
look,
I'm just going to show everybody how
tough I am and go through it anyway,
which you can do.
See if the thing is his back is
structurally sound.
The doctors cleared him,
so if he did like he thought in his
mind,
even though he does need to get the
pathways cleared out,
he's got some sort of stenosis where the
pathways to the nerves,
it's irritating as nerves,
but he can get a cortisone shot.
No,
he gets a cortisone shot.
Then he won't feel it.
He can go through the fight.
Structurally,
he's fine.
It's not like he's compromised and he's
got a weak joint,
so he goes,
it's just a little bit of pain.
He goes through it.
Then after the fight he can get the
surgery.
That's his doctor said.
So that's what he was saying.
He just didn't take consideration that
whenever
you say two things happen,
first of all the betting line changes.
You go and Tell everybody needs surgery.
After the fight there was a role,
so that gets squirrely.
Especially with Nevada.
They have to figure out how they,
how they put thIs lineup and second of
all there's the liability thing.
It's huge liability.
And then did you see they did offer the
fight of junior dos santos and then for
doom came out,
so I call calling junior dos santos gay
and it was like just come out the closet
said nothing.
It's homosexuals,
but everyone knows you're gay.
damn son.
Did he say that?
Yeah,
I went hard in the paint at jds.
Wow,
that's rough.
Super rough.
So do you see johnson?
That's not horizon.
Anytime soon.
Dc's just getting back to training on
monday,
dc had a torn muscle and he decided to
opt for surgery,
right?
Yeah,
right next to it.
So,
um,
he wenT for surgery on that surgery,
just getting back to training.
But who knows how long he's out.
Then he got John Jones is suspensions up
in july and then rumble said I'm the
only thing I'm doing is fighting for
title.
I'll wait a year if I have to,
but the ufc,
I'm like,
nah.
So near fight Jon jones for interim
title.
That's what I think's going to happen if
dcs not ready.
So joN jones comes back in july.
I think his,
his,
uh,
suspension is up right when that July
4th weekend card comes up.
Boom,
boom.
So he'll be probably the headline for
that.
That's a tough go because he had some
ring rust when he fought osp.
Yep.
Let's not get it twisted.
anthony rumble johnson.
You don'T get any mistakes with that
gentleman.
And also he had ring rust before the osp
fight and now it's another year off.
That's a this all long time off to your
point with rhonda,
run at 411 days off.
Ring rust is real,
man.
I don't give a fuck what people say and
not only is it real,
but you're not getting warm up fights
like she's not fighting liz carmouche
right?
You're fighting fucking this killer who
just fought at ufc 200.
Who's ready to go?
No warmup Is losing about bj.
Yeah,
year.
That's going to gary's.
Here's the future.
Scary.
You're.
Yeah,
you're rodriguez.
He's so dynamic,
man.
Clutch bj's at jackson's.
right,
man.
you know,
that's like a.
That's what everyone was saying.
Like,
oh,
bj needs a real camp.
He,
if pj went to jackson's or bj went here
aka or whatever,
and uh,
he actually listened and he did it a
little too late.
Yeah,
it's weird that it's too late.
It's never too late.
Those are,
that we have.
Here is a bad motherfucker.
But bj,
you know,
with the right camp,
just like everybody said it.
If he had the right camp,
he's got the right camp now.
Yeah.
But what happened?
Why?
What happened to his body where he's
going to 45,
like why is he going to 45?
Especially as you get back this real for
the kids.
That was always his real weight.
He was doing jujitsu at 1:47.
I was always this way.
Right.
But wasn't it like 12?
YeaH.
He was young as fuck.
And then he wanted the black belt worlds
at 1:47.
He fought machita for god's sakes.
Like he's funny.
He's a legend.
He's now.
I'll,
I'll
never.
I never root against bj.
Just goddamn.
Fortunately a year is.
That's a nightmare opponent for future
man.
But this is the best.
Bj.
We're going to see.
This is the best one.
That's it.
That's a strong statement at his age.
You know when I'm at the best possible
way.
Yeah,
that's what you're saying.
He has a great camp shape.
He's sticking around with dj.
Are you kidding?
You can't you get ate up?
Yeah.
It's 38 years old though and that's 38
mma years in 38 years old.
He takes some doors.
Jujitsu.
It's pretty goddamn stepson.
He's a mad scramble or fly to a knee
bar,
so I don't think so.
I don't think he's black or brown belt
levels.
Rodriguez,
bjj,
rank.
Okay.
I don't know.
Find that jamie.
Um,
but here's the thing about your year.
the distance.
He keeps that kicking distance.
He's fucking,
he's lethal on the beaches,
the quickness and stands with them.
Yeah.
The odds are not in his favor,
but if bj just decides to take it into
that clinch and take them down,
squeeze them out and jump on his neck.
I tHink that's the best route.
Not hundred percent.
He's got it.
He's got to take rodriguez.
I didn't like bj.
Verse llamas.
What the fuck is the legend,
man?
Look at him.
Ricardo lamas.
Carnal lumps a bad motherfucker.
I know.
So it was here.
But the problem is going to hurt you.
You didn't like that.
You don't think your year's going to
hurt you in the same way.
Ricardo is jesus.
Dude,
did you see the touchy feely fight when
he launched that fucking flying
roundhouse kick to his jaw and flattened
them?
Those are good points.
I'm just,
I didn't like the llamas fight for.
Um,
I think they're both equally scary.
The thing about pharmacists,
llamas has more experience against world
class competition.
Went five rounds with aldo and was
beating aldo in the fifth round and good
ground and pounding him.
He's got a nasty kia team to team
bermuda has cracked him to the punch and
then,
and then snuck in that tight arm and
guillotine.
He's very good.
Llamas is one of the best guys.
But he's also,
you know,
34,
35 do anything for bj that [inaudible]
and lama's is such a bad as he is.
So skilled that doesn't do much for bj
lately.
At least a year if he wins,
you know,
he's young.
that's a huge feather in his cap.
That makes more sense I guess.
But if bj beat,
I think if bj beat lama.
So it was a big feather in his calves.
Like jesus,
he beat a top 10 contender.
He's fought forever to us.
But what do you mean to anybody else?
Like,
well,
the only thing about,
or is it your year won the ultimate
fighter.
He won the latin America ultimate
Yeah.
Here's a motherfucker a motherfucker.
he really is.
People hate when we say that.
By the way,
when we stopped calling people,
multiple crews,
he was a beast.
Had motherfucker need more need for
adverbs to talk like me and my friends
is
a lot of god damn good fights on the
horizon.
There's a lot of potential fights.
If you're wonderboy,
wouldn't you be pissed at all?
This woodley talk about woodley
fighting.
AnybOdy else other than wonderful.
No one's even talking about wonderboy.
Yeah,
they forgot.
He started talKing shit to connor.
Woo.
I'll tell you what I'd watch.
Wonder believers.
Your boy tony ferguson.
Yeah,
but they're Just.
Well,
I'm on joy.
Does trading now.
Fuck way classes.
Listen,
cowboy has fought at 1:55,
one 70 [inaudible] fight between him and
tony harrison.
You guys were talking before.
I was seeing explosions are going off in
my head.
That's your guy.
Henderson.
I always get confused,
so I did it by 19 sprays to been taken.
Phrases you take lead on the lord's day.
We got nowhere to be and nothing to do
with the fuck.
Wow.
That's pretty scary as well.
It's tremendous.
I wrote them an email.
they wrote me back.
The nice people.
I've got to go up to the stop.
Get some more from them,
but some strong shit.
Huh?
Listen man,
if you guys are talking about we need
for a billion dollars when he fights.
This isn't it.
These are all the fights are going to
have to do now.
Going to say fuck weight class and just
making the biggest weight classes.
Everybody has to respect the weight
classes.
But uh,
go up.
If you want to go up,
if you think you could run with it,
run with it.
You got to convince dana the same way.
A kind of convinced they have some of
them jumbos have some of those brave.
One of these.
Exactly.
Can't see without my glasses to read
them to me.
Jumbos.
It's a fucking super powerful edible to,
to cookie dough truffles.
Yeah.
To tell you,
hey,
gluten free,
and I can go hang out with my faggy
friends.
Hang out,
go find that guy was going to suck.
Your dick doesn't take a smell.
THat organic.
He makes them with honey.
That's so good.
How many it tastes good.
District death.
All the above.
Read the strength of straight to the end
of the earth.
It doesn't say on there.
It tastes like dig.
Why does it taste like dick to organic
for you?
Chose you step process.
Sure.
It doesn't say how much is in there.
Exactly meant that as a compliment.
They don't even want you to know is
either truffle and he needed a boost of
energy.
What does it say about milligrams thc?
It doesn't say it.
Hm.
Interesting.
I feel like that's something you need to
know.
right?
I feel like that's important,
but this one says 25 milligrams.
Maybe I'll give you the wrong one.
This is pretty light.
Twenty five is not that bad for you.
That's nothing.
Twenty five milligrams.
1,200
last week.
Scam.
This one's 100,
but I think there's two of them in new
edible called this is 200 feet.
The two of them.
Listen,
there's a thing called moon.
Okay.
It's a chocolate bar.
It's 10 fucking dollars pen.
Donald's called moon.
I've beaten them twice.
How long have you known me?
A long tIme.
20 years.
Both times.
The next day I could not go to jujitsu
much.
I didn't do much the next day.
That strong.
What'd you do?
I ate the whole box.
And then what happened?
Dog.
You got to see pictures of me.
How many milligrams is at 250.
But they're lying to you.
Definitely to which I like.
I like being like,
I don't want to know what I'm eating
for.
I saw pictures of me and like I got hit
by new fudge.
That rocket fudge,
that shit will fucking kill you.
And here's the beauty that you go into
these places and they have all these $40
edibles and they have all these 10.
This is 10 fucking dollars.
You eat a half of that thing and you'll
be drooling.
And I gOt a better one.
There's one,
there's one called cushy.
They have 50 milligram or 100 and then
they have knocked out and listen to me.
It says it will activate in 60 minutes.
GuaranTee,
here's the thing about this is jamie,
jamie,
you,
it comes into punch that's super potent,
the,
the fucking uh,
worries and the recovery one,
but they've got one that is so fucking
strong and I call it transmission fluid
because when you open it up,
it comes to like a,
you know,
but you know,
you ever go eat breakfast,
the bundled packages,
you have to rip them open the life and
the comes on one of those and they chop
it in fours figure,
okay me,
I'm a guy.
I ate the whole bowl.
When You peel the top off and you smell
it and she like you walking into a
transmission shop like,
that's exactly where is it?
Not that high bred.
Not to get into k o,
t,
k o bitCh.
Oh my god.
Super potent gummy formula.
That's for high tones users.
Oh man,
it's a weird time because it's all legal
now.
Now that it's legal,
you're going to see what these dudes can
do.
You know,
because they're going to have to be held
back though because I think there's
regulations on the potency of edibles
now.
Is there,
I think you Just have to let people know
what's in them.
I think it's 10.
10.
Yeah,
so you can adjust.
Each one will be 10.
Like in denver they were selling these
like containers of 10.
It was 100 milligrams and they were
these gum drops and each one of them is
10.
They're pretty consistent but,
but not totally consistent.
Like I ate one.
I was like,
yeah,
it feels like 10.
And then another one that felt like 40
or 50.
I was like,
ooh,
this one,
they don't have the real numbers.
Not if you bring that cushy to you and
I'll make you eat the whole thing and
you'll go joey,
that's not 100 milligrams.
they lied to us.
That's the case.
often though.
I mean like it's hard to get real
accurate testing.
And then also like who's doing the
actual making and blend akin to
measurements.
Like tomorrow I pick up my shipment,
the attic,
he edibles.
Those are my home run my shipment.
Every monday,
every monday before jujitsu,
about 10:45,
he gives me 100,
200 milligrams,
100 red ones.
And a couple brownies brownies away to
my friends and I keep those for the
podcast when I fly and shit like that.
But then you have to get used to the
same strain.
It's like marijuana.
If you smoke the same training for three
days,
it's not going to get you as high as the
first day because you're telling them to
build to that strange.
So I make some match bitch.
I'm the only ones that allowed to mr.
Uncle joe is neighborhood a cushy,
cushy,
the tko brilliant fucking brilliant.
But that new rocket pocket,
that rocket chocolate,
that shit dog twice.
I read them already and I'm telling you
the next day I get up,
I take the baby to school,
I ride a little bit.
I'm like 10:30.
Then nothing going on.
I got to go right back to bed for four
or five hours.
Don't fucked up the next day.
There's gonna be a time in our lifetimes
where they start passing medical
psilocybin.
It's going to happen.
And when they have medical psilocybin,
eventually they're going to go with
recreational psilocybin.
And when they go with recreational
suicide,
when we're going to see a different
world,
it's going to be a different fucking
world.
But the same benefits that you've seen
with marijuana,
the difference being that marijuana,
at least when you're smoking it,
it's easier to regulate the experiences
and so world changing and dissolving.
But we're gonna.
We're gonna have freedom.
It'S not,
it's not here yet,
but it's here now for pot in a way
that's never been before.
I mean,
you think once a big pharma goes 100
percent in a cannabis,
what kinds of things do you think
they'll do to squeeze out the small
guys?
Because I,
you know what I mean?
They've already done it.
They tried.
They could make it.
Okay.
Now it's legal,
but we're the only ones that get.
Jamie wanted me to sell it if you're on
your own,
was that deal in Ohio and that seems
like,
like what's going to happen eventually?
The big businesses,
they're going to squeeze everybody out.
You're going to pass regulation.
JaMie?
Yeah.
They were trying to like lock down.
Like I think it was like for coMpAnies
that would have been able to grow,
it'll grow or sell or I think it was in
perpetuity forever.
That's what we're going to deal with
people like a regular person.
there's money in regular people.
Can they make like sick?
Can they start their own cigarette
companies?
Exactly.
Can they do that?
Right?
It's a good question.
Getting to the cigarette company.
No,
I think they,
they,
uh,
I dunno,
I don't know anything about it,
but I don't hear about people making
their own cigarettes.
You make your own wines and make your
own cigarettes.
If you buy your own tobacco and you can
roll your own.
But as far as like going into large
scale production,
yeah,
you're probably right.
Yeah.
The thing when you think about the
marijuana thing,
it's like you already know how easy it
is to grow you fucks,
you know,
the fact that they tried to lock it down
and make it so only a few companies can
grow it,
make it legal,
but only a few people can profit off it.
That's crazy.
And then then they make it so god
cheaped at that you've grown yourself
and trying to sell it yourself.
Just,
it just doesn't become an option
anymore.
They're not.
People just say fuck it,
you know,
they're just going to get cheap ass weed
at the liquor store,
at the gas station.
And they're just after a generation or
two people forget it.
It'll be like a kind of sewer thing in
the fucking 70,
60 minutes.
Did a show one time and they showed that
all already in the seventies.
The cigarette companies already had
farms set up.
They were already working on the
packaging.
Oh yeah,
in the seventies,
they were already trying to legalize
them.
The cigarette companies were already in
on it.
Right now we don't think all these
fucking cigarette companies are setting
up that Kentucky was that.
We're from Kentucky.
That's really good.
Kentucky,
uh,
they have a weaving can,
like I'll ask guys like matt neufeld fun
to fuck Kentucky has like that blue
grass family.
I went up there.
Once somebody brought me that weed,
they're going to package all those the
same way they package poco gold member
gold.
And I think there'll be a marlboro
cannabis dirty get involved in.
I guess we have a mutual friend his
name,
but he's in the marijuana business
account.
No,
I wish.
But uh,
he was saying that that's the issues
that those big cigarette companies are
buying up so much shit to make it hard
for other people get involved in.
Yeah.
Like they already have their hand in
something that's selling like hotcakes.
Eventually the small,
the small man gets cut out.
Right?
Yeah.
It happens a lot.
Certainly happens a lot.
Whenever there's anything regulations
where you know they can profit and they
can use their influence and fuck over
people.
That also could probably relate.
The problem with pot is it's so god damn
easy to grow that if they don't do that,
anybody could step in.
But what they were trying to do in Ohio,
lock it down for perpetuity forever.
You know,
that these companies could be the only
ones they're set up.
They're setting up monarchies.
Common.
No,
that's not you.
We haven't heard the end of that shit.
Hell no.
That's coming.
Well,
it's gonna be interesting when trump's
the president now see where they go with
all this because that jeff sessions got
that.
He's bringing in that guy hates box.
They're not going to let these hippies
make millions of dollars.
That's only going to last.
These are going to be considered the
good old days.
They're going to wish you was never
legal.
Who knows?
We're going to find out.
It's going to be interesting to.
Trump has said that he's going to leave
it up to the states,
but presidents always say shit that they
don't do.
I mean obama was going to close down
guantanamo bay.
That motherfucker still open eight years
later.
He never even made an attempt at it.
I think sometimes they say that stuff.
They don't realize how much work goes
into it.
Right.
Well,
I think they say that and then they get
into office and then they get handed
some dossiers and some fucking briefings
and they understand like he went like,
this is why we haven't done like,
look,
I know you were saying you're going to
close down [inaudible] bay because it
helps your campaign,
but we're going to get you in here and
show you what the fuck those guys.
They didn't sit them down.
They knew that shit way before they knew
what they were getting into.
Maybe the only reason they were allowed
to rise so high.
I think they say a bunch of shit to get
in the office.
They say whatever the fuck they don't
know for sure.
They lie their ass off.
Like everything that comes out of like
hillary's mouth.
I mean like do you watch house of cards?
It was like a george w dot bush.
Like everything that George W.
Bush says when he talks got damn we got
into conspiracies are bullshit.
Meter doesn't go off right?
Well he didn't even get to the part.
Tell them about admin.
The can see.
I hate though.
Maybe that's the key.
So let's end it.
It's a,
it's 8:10.
This is a good fucking podcast,
man.
Happy new year.
Happy to see you man.
Thank you times.
Ladies and gentlemen.
We'll be back tomorrow with a hashtag
who is fat week thompson and bert
kreischer weighing tomorrow at 11:00
AM.
They've been losing weight for months
now.
And tom is right writing hashtag
[inaudible] fat burn right in.
Hashtag thomas fat.
Tom and I both started out at about two
67 in that range.
And now,
uh,
they're,
they're fucking light.
I can't wait to see.
Tom looks fantastic.
Tom's only been drinking water.
That's it.
He doesn't even drink.
Soda.
Doesn't drink diet soda doesn't drink
coffee anymore.
He's just drinking water to my favorite
people.
Super disciplined.
He looks fucking great.
She'd see the videos of his face.
But can we see that real quick before we
go secure as instagram before you leave?
Because he's got a real funny video.
We'll,
we'll leave it on this and then we'll
show one at burt's to balance it out.
But thompson is instagram.
There's a video of him talking to the
cameras because burt put this video of
he ran for five and a half hours and
lost like 3000 fucking calories because
birth is savage.
I mean he's a psychopath psycho.
He's not the discipline guy that tom is.
Tom is more slow and steady wins the
race and bert is like,
I will run to like die right now.
I went to his house for christmas eve or
christmas day with the kids.
He's a burly girl,
was a kid.
Then when he was outside the sauna and
they were like,
get in there and I can't.
Right.
So it looks homey that tom go to tom
[inaudible] is going on like a fucking.
He starved himself right now.
I'm looking at the play that I saw a old
ass birds
instagram and you fucking suckers
believe in it.
That's called playing catch up.
Catch up,
have covered so many more miles in you
have in this beautiful,
perfect fucking beard.
You shaved the beard,
man.
You should run all night.
I don't want to see
run every day.
Don't even have to fucking run anymore.
I already had your ass beat.
He looks great already.
I'm heading the game and I am watching a
fucking bowl game because I know I wait.
List
you fat motherfucker.
Look how good he looks.
Great.
Let's go to a bird
here.
Has to talk to tom the other day and I
told him I'm turning on the nitrous
oxide to this weight loss challenge.
I want to see what the nitrous oxide is.
Twenty two miles.
God done five hours and 23 minutes.
How many calories?
3,000.
Two hundred and 66 at an average of
four.
Point one.
This is that mickey mantle gene and I
always talk about that long strand dna.
That part of your brain that won't let
you quit.
It forces you to go that extra 22 miles
to make sure you don't lose your beard
will be weighing in.
Live on youtube,
on joe rogan's podcast,
the joe rogan experience,
January 2nd or January 3rd.
Tune in to find out who loses their
beard.
I can tell you one thing,
it won't be the guy killing it.
It'll be the guy laying in bed watching
a ballgame right now,
a big tummy bonds.
I hope you got a sponsorship from dollar
shave club because I'm coming and I'm
coming for your beard.
I love those guys.
It's hilarious,
but honestly it's going to be real
interesting to see whether burt's
craziness can balance out tom's
discipline because tom has been
disciplined for a long time.
Man.
I've been watching him.
He.
He does an hour of fucking cardio every
day.
Every day.
He's not taking any days off.
he's not drinking at all.
eating at all.
Births been drinking this whole time.
Burt still drinking.
You don't think he drank last night.
It was new year's eve,
you know a couple of cocktails,
a cup of vodka sodas and it just figures
it.
I'll just find out what a vodka soda is
and I'll burn that off on the treadmill.
Yeah.
Was I supposed to be water skinny bitch
water?
It's kind of.
It's really a vodka tonic or vodka.
Soda water.
They call it skinny bitch.
Yeah,
man.
Really interesting.
He always does his shirts with his sets.
He does.
He takes his shirt off like seconds into
being on stage,
but it's funny because he's skinny or
because he's fat,
like if he gets skinny,
you can't just take your shirt off and
be jack because he's a big fella.
He put something.
He put a picture of this guy wrote a
comic on that.
Maybe you'd had a bit of.
Don't hang that on the mic and makes
noise.
Oh,
I remember that.
You knew.
Had a bit about that.
These comments that people write when
the fuck did they get off these?
There was just one on there that he's
just making a statement that guys like,
you can't find a shirt that fits you.
What the fuck do these people get all
retarded fucking life.
These people don't.
That's why they're sad fucking world to
live in when you just.
I remember oNe day duncan sent me a a
thing that he did when I read it shit
and a bunch of people and they were like
talking to you about like fat comics
that they shouldn't that one.
Have you ever seen the successful fat
comIc?
Spent up?
Fucking shitload of them,
and I was reading this going,
what planet?
Oh,
you fuck.
Just dark people.
Sam fat
is all korean candy balloon.
Yo,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
Anyway,
this motherfucker,
man,
remember when you were 16?
You were mcginn gay dudes.
If you had an instagram account,
you'd probably be talking shit to
thompson.
The same thing.
The same thing do.
I had a guy and it's very real.
I ever get back to him.
This guy said something just ruthless,
and I was like,
god damn it.
I clicked on his profile and it's him.
A picture of him holding his daughter so
I just can't.
I said,
dude,
you got a fucking kid,
man.
I get.
He might hit me.
Don't be that loser comment.
Another man's fucking instagram page.
you got a fucking kid for god's sakes,
and now you a black you for being a
moron
if people can't help it.
EverYbody likes to come.
You're morons.
Morons like to comment.
They can make a kid.
It's just a bummer.
That's the end,
but he's in gentlemen will be a moron.
Don't be a moron,
but you know what,
man?
this whole being a moron thing,
even that it's temporary and it's like
we're coming to a head.
It's,
it's not far away.
Folks.
There will be integration.
All of Us will be connected in some
strange hive mind and we're about Five,
maybe 10 years away from it.
It won't be as simple as like send a
fuCking tweet or anything.
It's going to go right to your brain and
everyone's going to be aware that you
did it and they're all going to be able
to go back at you and we're going to
share information in a way that's just
as weird to us today as the internet was
30 years ago.
Nobody ever thought you'd have to deal
with this shit mecha back when rick
james was a fucking on top of the world
today,
you think you would add a d,
w look at his instagram page like,
what the fuck are they saying?
Oh,
rick james.
It was a weird time when everybody can
just talk to you.
They're going to be.
It's going to be more than that.
The next level is go right into your
brain.
I don't like that.
I don't like it either,
but it's happening.
Deal with it.
Bitch tomorrow.
Who is hashtag?
Who is fat?
Starts at 11:00
AM pacific time.
Uh,
eddie bravo.
Matt flavor.
Brendan shop.
That's it.
Big brown breakdown tomorrow.
Big brown break down tomorrow.
You fucks.
See ya.
I love ya.
Bye.